[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is the
return of the incredible hilarious and
wonderful Bert Kreischer who has a new
movie you're about to hear we talk a
little bit about it not not a ton but I
did gush quite a bit because I went and
I saw it and I [__] loved it and it's
available streaming on like Apple TV you
get on your iTunes you can get you can
buy it on YouTube I'm pretty sure
youtube.com is a website but I loved it
he's fantastic he's so funny it's so him
and you gotta check it out it's it's
really gave me so many laughs and so
many laughs at both Val and I need it so
badly that's so hard to do so check out
the machine which is available on demand
now if you'd like some live laughs some
ll's go to petehomes.com because I'm on
tour I'm going to be in New York and I
think New Jersey Connecticut I don't
know Denver that sounds right I'm going
to be adding St Louis that'll be
available soon listen I'm going all
around and it just and even after this
tour is done of this hour I'm going to
continue touring and doing more dates as
I work out my next hour so regardless of
when you hear this I'm probably coming
to a town you're near you go to
petehomes.com and I hope to see you out
there it means so much when people come
to the shows also if you like this show
we do ads a little bit differently here
we only do spots for things I actually
use and actually love like this I'm
wearing it right now if you're watching
the video this is my Apollo neuro
there's no piece of tech that has
changed my life in the past years more
than the Apollo neuro it's a wearable
that helps your body recover from stress
by sending vibrations into your body
that gives your nervous system the
sensation of being touched or held that
means it's like a digital or like a
virtual hug which is so incredible it
can help you relax sleep focus and be
more productive a wearable hug for your
nervous system using touch therapy to
help you feel safe and in control and I
can tell you and Val can tell you it
absolutely Works worn on the wrist or
the ankle of hollow neuros like finding
the fuse box for your emotions that's
what I like to say with settings for
energy social Focus rebuild and recover
calm unwind which is what I put it on at
night to help me wind down at the end of
the day then I put it on fall asleep
which is a chemical free way to lull you
to sleep or if you get up in the middle
of night to low you back to sleep I use
it every night at least one full
rotation of the cycle a polynero is not
woo-woo it's not like developed by the
Psychic Friends Network it was developed
by a neuroscientist and a
board-certified psychiatrist who've been
studying the impacts of chronic stress
in humans for nearly 15 years and
Apollo's effects on stress sleep
cognitive performance and Recovery have
been proven in multiple clinical trials
in real world studies so do your nervous
system a favor do this show a favor show
your support of the show but also help
your body help your mind get 10 off at
apollonuro.com weird that's Apollo
follow any url.com slash weird ten
percent off also brought To Us by our
friends speaking of productivity at on
it on it Alpha Brain is the supplement
that has absolutely changed it's a game
changer for me it is a new atropic it is
Earth grown ingredients it is not a
stimulant it helps you with memory and
focus and creativity and flow anytime
I'm doing something that involves my
brain if it's Reading Writing if I'm
doing a podcast if I'm doing stand-up or
as I'm just this weekend like on the
fourth I will take some Alpha Brain
because I want to have access in my
brain even if I'm just hanging out and
being social when do you not want your
brain to have the nutrition that it
needs to function at its Optimum it is
incredible I wish I knew about it in
college I'm so glad I know about it now
the best way to know if you like it is
to try it Go to
onitonnit.com weird you will get 10 off
everything you see on that landing page
try Alpha Brain absolute creative and
productivity Game Changer support the
show on it.com slash weird alright
everybody let's get into Bert Kreischer
he returns right now get into it
you were you you were the first person
that I said I need a cake
no it's real everybody needs a Candy I
swear to God I was so good to see I've
been thinking about how have you been
doing
good how's life been so sweet yeah I
love this so awesome I've known I've
known Katie now for [__] 15 years no
I know I know
no I love Katie she's wonderful you're
still working with her still working
that's so [__] awesome together
now we're self-produced but we were with
nerdists which is how we got our started
notice that's so interesting are we
rolling we're rolling I notice is really
interesting dude shout out to Chris
Hardwick he is such an inventive [__]
Next Level dude but uh yeah he changed
my life
expect me to do a pod and we used to
text each other just the word game
changer I didn't mean to interrupt which
is with you I want to give him some love
because he was like you should do it
because I was like what it's just just
talking and he's like you don't
understand I would argue I would argue
can I tell you this I'm gonna say this I
hope that you take this as a compliment
me if you didn't have extracurriculars
in your career meaning TV shows movies
all uh tours if you just had focused on
Stan on podcasting you'd be bigger than
Rogan you think so yeah you were so I
think you got distracted with a lot of
the bigger things in your life the Pete
home show the [__] uh crashing and
which were all [__] amazing I would I
would gladly in the career that we both
have chosen we've chosen to do the
extracurriculars yeah yeah for whatever
reason they were those kids we do band
yeah I want to be challenged in other
things like Joe just I think Joe already
did them all yeah and was done he didn't
Peak but he broke early that's the word
I'm looking for you know in secret time
Joe got put in time out for a little bit
tell me uh you know uh
no one no Joe got put in timeout
after doing The Man Show and then the
Carlos Mencia thing it all happened at
the same time after the man show because
I got offered the man show uh I got off
for The Man Show
yeah why weren't you the host of the man
show no well you know can I can I tell
you can I tell you why what do you mean
they offered me The Man Show uh probably
2014-15 we just started doing Joe's
podcast and Joe's podcast was big and
it's really when we came Joe became like
a little bit of a like a I say big
brother I don't really like using the
word Mentor because
uh I never like mentors to grandiose big
brother like where I could go like
that's the word men and then you guys
would like that I like that
yesterday and he is so [__] perfect
he's a beautiful man so I called Joe I
was in Edmonton they offered me The Man
Show they said you can have anyone guest
host it uh you beat you and then you can
pick whoever you want to co-host it with
and I called Joe and I said hey man uh I
just got offered the man show I know you
did it what do you think he was don't do
it please don't do it please don't do it
it's not worth it
he's like listen man I got put a little
bit of a TV time out after I did it
because it no one no one liked it and I
and and it kind of [__] me for a
little bit wait because people didn't
like how unpc it was no no no is it that
it just didn't perform well it wasn't
good so whenever you get whenever you
have it maybe it was good it just didn't
perform well it didn't perform well it
wasn't it wasn't Jimmy and Adam yeah
Jimmy and Adam had a special chemistry
yeah they were special dudes and they
were doing something at a time when it
was unacceptable and and girls on
trampolines I remember watching that
going like yeah it's [__] perfect
right I wanted that to be the whole show
when I was 15. I was like why wasn't can
I tell you it still works and there's
porn out there pretty excessively still
works it still works I saw girls on
trampoline the other day and I went
that's [__] cool yeah that's [__]
cool I like it to have like a like a
light flare to it like I like frolicking
I love uh Doug Benson used to do side
boobs Sundays yeah and his fans would
just send pictures of side boobs and I
go yeah [__] works yeah now I know
under boob too oh under boobs like down
when a woman when a woman is not wearing
a bra and they lean forward to talk to
you and you're supposed to like you get
that moment of of of of
analystick where you see it you go I
look and then you look away because
you're a gentleman but you're the party
was a man where you're like she [__]
knows yeah she knows she's doing this to
me have you ever thought about this if
you and I were women I feel like would
be the similar style brassy broads I say
that with with love I'd have like a a
like a dragon tattoo high on my thigh I
might have red hair can I yeah yeah I'd
have red hair too can I tell you I
really put this together one point that
doing stand-up is our attempt to be hot
women
do you know what I mean yeah you walk
through the Mall of America and people
are as as excited to see you as they
would just not just but like a beautiful
like Joan from Mad Men walk through same
level of enthusiasm I said that uh
yogurt I was talking to my my lady who
runs my social media we were stuck in
traffic and we were talking about what
percentage of uh the opposite sex do you
think you could have sex with and she's
very attractive and she said I think I
could have sex with 100 of men amen and
I said I was like yeah that's actually
pretty accurate I said what about me and
she goes I don't know like 30 and I was
like wait hold on are you doing just me
as me or me as if I have my career I
have she goes oh well that's a little
bit of a game changer of course because
it's it is it is true I could get it's
not fair either that I mean look both of
us are married men so we're talking in
this fantasy parallel universe yeah but
I could get girls I don't deserve
interesting
what is attractiveness
oh this is externalization so okay I'm
gonna I'm really deep I love where I'm
gonna give this to you okay Rob Lowe
tell me about Rob Lowe tell me about Rob
Lowe's jawline is it chiseled every part
of his face yes is perfectly measured
yes so symmetry symmetry symmetry is
also just a genetic indicator real teeth
real teeth he has real teeth we can't be
sure about that no I watch I watch I I
pick on real teeth you got real teeth I
got real teeth I don't have real teeth
can you tell when people don't have real
teeth it turns me off when you see
someone how do you know oh they're too
perfect
yeah yeah Chiclet teeth but a square jaw
everybody who listens to this podcast
knows I'm gonna say this but a square
draw is an indication of high
testosterone so is body hair so this is
how you're sexy you are projecting to
women like manliness like Bert Kreischer
without a beard I can't grow a beard
these are indications of testosterone
think of Jason Statham he's balding
Bruce Willis he's balding high
testosterone what's testosterone it's a
poison so if you are a man and you have
high testosterone it means you're strong
it means you have grit it's the same
thing machine I'm calling you machine on
purpose here alcohol is a poison why is
you drinking 12 Manhattans in an hour
like seeming like why is that cool why
is it cool that Don Draper's smoking a
cigarette and having a cocktail at noon
because testosterone and alcohol chisel
jaw hairy back baldness all these things
are indications of how your genes can
handle a competitive environment there
are things that are trying to kill you
so I'm talking about on a base
unconscious level a woman looks at you
and goes he can survive I won't breed
with him and he'll drop dead yeah now
think of what uh you know like what what
we've in the 80s would call like a nerd
like you know like a high-pitched voice
yeah they do they have a beard
no no they have a square jawline no no
oh yeah yeah yours weekend these are
indications so symmetry is also an
indication of an internal order it's
interesting right yeah so Rob Lowe's
perfect phase Denzel Washington's
perfect face it says to a woman just
like big hips say to a man we're talking
very heteronormal very like I I
understand but a man we see wide hips
that means a baby can come out without
splitting this woman in half we see big
boobs they can feed the baby you know
what I'm saying these are we're pretty
basic yeah there's a lot of variations
on this but when you're talking so you
getting women you you don't deserve I
would take issue with that because you
can make people laugh humor is an
indication that you have higher function
which means you're not going to resort
to violence first you're going to go to
your intelligence first are you going to
go to your reason I would argue I
wouldn't you know it's interesting you
say that I've never resorted to violence
like I've never resorted like it's not
is it really a resort
I was telling something today I learned
very quickly as a dude with a sense of
humor who you can [__] with and who you
cannot [__] with some people yeah it's
not on the menu and you know It's tricky
because I live in a world where like a
lot of MMA fighters listen to our
podcast and so and I [__] around with a
lot of MMA fighters is it MMA I've been
saying
[Music]
you're talking to the toughest
[__] you've ever met and he's
shirtless and he's glistening but he
keeps saying ma instead of MMA yeah
I don't correct anyone people people can
say the n-word in front of me and I just
go uh-huh sure thing pal just can you
say it lower I'm getting the [__] out of
here
boy is also an indication of uh genetics
Superior dude I don't correct anyone
I've had black dudes say horrifically
homophobic [__] out loud at a restaurant
and you're just like
how many blooming onions will it take to
apologize to everyone correct anybody
and I will not correct an MMA fighter I
will not correct an MMA fighter which is
why I think you're still here oh yeah
well although it's a learning curve are
they gentle little beans no dude they're
not no no no the vast majority of them
are [__] awesome like awesome they
are as awesome as Rogan is and Rogan is
Rogan would never ever ever in a million
years resources of violence because
those dudes a lot of them
understand
they they can they could beat the [__]
out of out of you right they don't I
don't think that they I think the
majority of them are smart enough
there's a there's a little gray area of
dudes who would resort to violence there
are there are a couple of them I know
but like for the most part you can bust
balls with any of them yeah and they'll
all they appreciate it like uh well
they're probably used to people being
afraid of them all the time Israel is
the
inarguably the probably the baddest
[__] around yeah
uh middleweight champion of the world
and I challenged him to a fight I said I
could kick his ass if we hold on hold on
if if we both started drinking at the
same time and we had to drink 12 Beers
and then get in the cage and then and
then he kind of giggled and like sent me
a text like that's actually an
interesting fight because I don't drink
much so like and I drink a lot so and so
just [__] around that's your
handicapped but it's just talking [__] I
don't mean your handicapped I mean like
he would be at a deficit but that's
that's [__] around on the podcast and
then I met him in New Zealand and he he
dashed me up and like grabs me and like
puts his hand behind my neck very big
hands very soft hands very big hands
yeah and he throws a soft knee to my
stomach and he pulls me in tight and he
goes you still think you can [__] me up
and I was like oh this was a
miscalculation also he was holding on to
he was holding me and I wasn't moving
yeah I wasn't moving yeah
still hurt a little bit I bet yeah
that's a bony knee he is and his body
moves with intention yeah oh you just
scared me he's not even here yeah when
you're like if you were like peep you
can go fight that guy I just want you to
know his body moves with intention the
Diaz brothers uh the Diaz brothers
aren't like fair game I wouldn't say you
can make fun but like I think these are
the twins from Breaking Bad no no no
this is Nick and Nate Diaz the home
renovation guys yeah yeah yeah yeah they
they cut their cousins they do kitchens
and so yeah
they should do a home renovation show
and they break the walls themselves yeah
dude that's a [__] great idea in
stock I feel like you could sell that
tomorrow it's like it's MMA fighters and
they'll redo their home but instead of
using sledgehammers and stuff they throw
guys through the wall I just and yeah
yeah
demo is the part the funnest part to
watch but then it would be cool to see
their design choices
yes that would would Steve would show up
for the demo would stay for the horrible
design the reveal to like to like uh
like a very artsy alternative couple
that identify as as yes and then Nick
and Nate Diaz are like yo leather walls
what do you mean you don't want black
leather walls yo we made you a smoking
porch and they're like what they're been
notorious Billy big Stoners right so
that's why you know they have a good
sense of humor is if they smoke pot yeah
and Shane Gillis is good friends with
with Nate and uh and I'm Nate Diaz Nate
Diaz I'm just wearing this you don't you
don't like you know there's a you know
that if you say something you have to
really mean it as a joke they have to
you you want that's the thing with tough
guys and I love to know your intent they
have to know your time because they you
and I only speak joking yeah but they
also these are guys that would pick up
the frequency of like or maybe you know
you want to [__] find out
because there are some dudes yeah who do
that of course there are guys there are
guys that we've dealt with in this
business that think they're comics and
they think they're tough guys and they
do like Alpha [__] to you sometimes
that's not cool oh yeah and then and you
go like I'm not gonna hit you with the
Improv right and I would never hit you
but that is a weird thing to do okay so
there's actually a lot of parallels here
I think when you show up in a situation
I have to imagine like most Comics
you're not really interested in being
the funniest person at the party right
most I go the other way really no no I
mean I'm with you I go people will be
like Pete's kind of quiet you know what
I mean and if somebody is like wants to
juggle and do bits and stuff I'm like
[__] happening on my shirt you're
still drinking the Kool-Aid yeah what
the [__] I don't know I'm [__] 50 and
I'm still spilling Kool-Aid on me
the [__]
are those men spilling
they're spilling water I think
God damn it no it looks like I'm
bleeding
[__] [__] yeah give it to me
well thanks Pete
thanks be welcome bro thanks Pete you're
my guest thanks
Be Our Guest with some Kool-Aid on your
chest you're a man and you drink
Kool-Aid and you're 50 at the best
oh don't cough during my ribs I'm just
kidding it actually feels pretty nice
it's cool is so [__] good man is it
it's awesome do you think that big
talking picture has your best interests
at heart yeah yeah he's coming through
your wall first of all that's how you
know he doesn't really give a [__] you
know about you after the transition you
walk into a room and there's a lot of
villains in the room right there's
alcohol there's cigarettes there's
there's zins there's there's guns and
it's a tobacco that like all the Young
Dudes do all the bar stool geysers and
zins
it up his little pouch it's like a
snooze okay and so there's tobacco
there's there's drugs there's Xanax
there's
hey man you deserve a treat and I don't
want to kill you I mean I'm not crazy
for you but do you want a little treat
and you're like oh yeah
and then you go and because like today I
was like I was like I ate two Edibles
last night and I've had a hard time
turning the corner this morning oh
getting up and then I went and worked
out really hard and I was just like and
I was like I need a treat I need
something to like look forward to
I can't wait I love it I love it so much
it's interesting when you drink it does
it take you back I have a lot more on me
but you have a lot more yeah no it takes
would you mind
a little because people are only going
to see mine yeah no I know they're gonna
be like who's yeah you really took a
[__] swing at it commit to the BET
commit to the bit commit to the BET let
me ask you this so you drink it how much
of it is Nostalgia because I saw Tom
making fun of you on Instagram and I
loved it yeah I just loved how you you
kind of turn into like 15 year old
version of you like your face reverts
and it's very sweet and like he's
laughing so hard yeah something about
Tom laughing when he gets really
laughing you're almost like what is he
thinking that he's not saying like
there's something terrible there's a lot
to these things there's worse things
that he's not saying or thinking but
when you drink it does it take you back
to that time because I'm smelling it
yeah and it's bringing me back to like
Little League
I think there's something about it
that uh
that kind of bright it I feel like it
brightens my day because I take a sip I
go yeah
I'm gonna this is this is gonna sound
like placement so you know what element
is yeah drink an element at night make a
hot make a make a salt chocolate hot
element at night that's my instead of
like a cocktail or wheat or something I
I sound so 44 right now yeah but I make
my the reason is I only do it at night
so when I make it my brain goes it's
treat time even though it's a zero
calorie you know hydration multiplier we
were doing we were doing element uh
Margaritas I believe that would be great
they're [__] awesome I struggled not
to drink like five of them that's my
biggest problem with them is I only want
to drink that you know what else is
really good is liquid IV liquid IV is
really good too I like liquid Ivy but it
has sugar in it it has like 11 12 grams
of sugar in it not a concern for Mr
Kool-Aid but not on my map I'm not
seeing that road I uh I'm over here
going like just strip it away element
has no sugar now we're just this sounds
like a commercial but no no but I like I
like element I like liquid IV but like
whatever you got me through covet it
helped me
it really works like in the mornings if
you're hungover you drink a liquid IV
and you bounce back I would say put up
put a put an element to that test let's
get that I'll do I'll tell you what I'll
go strict element for a week and see how
I feel there you go
um I uh I was we were you got something
no because we were talking about whether
or not you're funny at a party oh yeah
because I was saying that's if you know
that you're funny
you don't have to prove it these guys
know that they're tough so they don't
have to prove it no that must be a nice
little relief but you were also starting
to say I think that people do [__] with
them I have to imagine people in the
same way if I see you at a party and I'm
just a regular guy a non-comedian I mean
I might want to go up and be like I was
funnier than that guy oh there's there's
definitely guys that will
will push and challenge because they
think you know they're not that [__]
tough yeah and and and I've I've seen it
and then you've and I've seen it like
I've seen like little wrestling matches
go wrong and and really oh yeah little
like good-natured like goodness you're
ribbing turn into like whoa he's up
against the elevator like what the [__]
you can't well you're talking about
they're in their body
if you sometimes I will get in a
situation where my comedian reflex kicks
out and suddenly I'm saying [__] or
something oh yeah I'm just like all
right most people don't jump to that
we're we're at a point if you do the
thing where you throw them against the
elevator comedically yeah exactly you
say it you're like [__] it I can beat
any Asian in a foot race everyone's like
what
the [__]
[Laughter]
so you grab someone who's used to in
their body like if if I hand you
something like you your your hand just
goes out like you know what I mean and
if I grab you they just go into like
some sort of stance yeah and now a
knee's going up they didn't mean it dude
I uh so if I go to a it's funny I've
changed a lot back in the day
when I had nothing going on in my career
I would have to be the funny guy at the
party me too but it was the worst I was
unbearable me too I I could argue I
could argue that I I was unbearable yeah
and especially if there was a network
exact there buddy I was pitching him
shows I I couldn't shut the [__] up let
me join you let me join you in the shame
pool guess who got real lit real drunk
and pitched a movie to Ben Stiller
I love that I love that outside it was
at a meltdown party and I even drunk I
saw in his face
you know he's a good communicator with
his face his face said please don't
please don't he like it was a Kabuki
theater like back row would have known
Ben Stiller does not want to hear this
movie idea
that's [__] isn't that crazy so you
would so I'm with you I I I are
excitable I'll take one further I had a
friend
married to a network executive and I
couldn't understand how they didn't
pitch their spouse all day long yeah and
I was like I mean that's what we do
right right I was so bad
and then when I got a little a little
bit of success I started getting
comfortable in my skin
and now I actually there's been a couple
parts especially if I'm not drinking I I
get to a party and I am so quiet yeah
that everyone say what's everyone's
what's wrong with you what's wrong
nothing yeah you got to find that middle
ground yeah that middle which by the way
speaking of balance
dude
for real like the most sincere
compliment I [__] loved your movie oh
thank you I [__] loved it and let me
let me make it even better I think as a
compliment
um I put it on and I was like I'll watch
10 minutes yeah like not not because I
didn't think it would be good I was just
like most things aren't for me yeah and
I was like I don't know I don't know
I'll throw it on Val's rocking the baby
I'll throw it on nope Val comes down
we're starting this [__] again
he loved it I don't mean I hate that I'm
revealing that I'm kind of like a lazy
curmudge and I'm like I just want to see
some of the movies I know you get that I
get that because I do that with a lot of
things but it wasn't a vote of no
confidence in you it was just kind of
like most things aren't for me I can see
things coming a little ways ahead like I
like I can I thought I would be watching
your movie and being like and is this
gonna happen I was surprised thank you
thank you and I don't want to ruin it
for anybody but there's the moment in
the elevator yeah yeah we laughed like
10. Val and I alone meaning I wish I had
seen it in the theater I might still go
see it in the theater but like to see it
with a group and you are [__] great
in it thank you so much Pete that is a
real compliment I'm so hard on other
Comics I really am like because I see
what we do I see how we're uncomfortable
yeah we don't know how to connect if
we're not talking in the scene we're
like like frozen you were making choices
you were loose in your body you were in
the scene and I'm gonna tell you here
I'm sorry for all these compliments but
I really just want to get the word out
like I I was like I'll watch it as my
friend I'm gonna like it and I loved it
and the thing that came to mind I was
like this you're like our Tim Allen you
know what I mean I was like you're the
Santa Claus you're that's that's coming
from a lot of Santa Claus roles
I swear to God I've gotten so many Santa
Claus Scripts so many Santa Claus
scripts that like Santa Claus scripts to
a point I was like yeah I was like do I
need to lose weight like what's going on
they're like no it's really a powerful
thing to do a Christmas movie yeah
because they keep coming back and that's
what agents want you to do right but uh
yeah it's built in into that thank you
so much Pete that means you from scene
one from scene one I was like with your
family and and I saw you put
vulnerability in it too that's the other
thing I was like oh I bet it's just you
know I bet it's like a fun Wild movie
yeah and then there's all this heart in
it and there's all the and you did the
work as an artist you're gonna make me
cry thank you that is very sweet of you
I I almost texted you but I was like I'm
gonna tell them on the show and and
again I'm embarrassed that I went in
just kind of being like who knows I
shouldn't have doubt it but I do that
I've done that I've done that with a lot
of things mostly I do that with specials
I watch a lot of specials well that's
that's what it was I watch a lot of
specials and I just go like okay I can
still like the person and be like okay
and then and and she's not for me is the
cleanest thing you can say go I'm not
I'm not I'm never going to talk [__]
about this person other people might
love them just not for me and and it's
also [__] beautiful it's shot
beautifully oh thank you and the
Transitions and the subtitles there's a
lot of intention it wasn't just and this
is why I'm happy to share this on the
show it wasn't just a movie that you can
make it's like it wanted to be a movie
it was Scotty Landis they wrote this
great script you [__] nailed it and
you surrounded yourself with this cast
is there a dud on that cast it's [__]
everyone is dope we had a ball and we
were tired we have a four and a half
year old we need laughs but going back
to what I was saying you know your
therapist wrote like deep insecurity
right yeah and then there's you talking
about needing balance and there's the
real hurt whether or not it's your
father in real life but there's a real
herd of parents not understanding us
yeah and to play that out and to see
you discover balance I know this sounds
like I'm blowing smoke no but I was like
you need that you because I know what a
Persona is I know what it's like to go
into my comedy power and I know what
it's like to go into my daddy power like
being a dad and being a partner and
being a friend and being just a regular
person at the at the library and like I
just really I think it's a really great
thing and I hope I hope
if you want to keep doing stuff like
that I hope you do oh Pete that is I'm
gonna clip this out send this to me and
I'm going to play this every time I feel
low because like you do feel low at
times regardless and you go why man
what's going on with me and then like uh
you know pulling out today a guy said to
me um hey man I saw your movie you guys
didn't expect to say that and he's like
my buddy's going through something and
and he said it's exactly what he needed
yeah and then you go oh and then you
like it's hard because you want to close
your eyes and go I remember this
compliment yeah this I want this
compliment to stick with me for the day
well that's what you should do by the
way yeah well I I think of because you
have to you have to hold on to it
intentionally a negative one you don't
have to try no yeah right crazy yeah
hold on can I tell you a story please
Larry David this I got from father Greg
Boyle who is a is a mentor of mine and a
friend
um he sounded so show busy and a friend
I just mean I love him to death yeah
that's all I mean is he a real priest
he's a real priest yeah
okay yeah you know if you don't know
father Greg Boyle read listen to tattoos
on the heart you will love it really and
you should be giving to homeboys and
Homeboy Industries
yeah oh shut up yeah yeah we should do a
benefit and we're doing it I've stopped
by them they used to be an American
Airlines I don't know if America yeah
they're still there but I used to stop
there all the time I would but the line
is usually too low the lines are crazy
yeah so he told this story in his book
uh barking of the choir and I and I'm
gonna put it back to you because I don't
want to talk too much but I am excited
to tell you how much I loved your movie
so Mary David Larry David goes to a
Yankee game and it's his birthday and
his friends or whoever he's with tell
the management that Larry David is there
and that it's his birthday so seventh
inning stretch they put him on the
Jumbotron there he is Larry David
Standing Ovation the whole however many
tens of thousands of people that is or
if it's 10 I don't know it's a lot of
[__] people
Standing Ovation for Larry David which
by the way I believe because my father
he transcends everything and he's and he
is New York yeah and he's New York so
they go nuts Standing Ovation then as if
that weren't enough they sang Happy
Birthday the whole stadium sings happy
birthday to him another Ovation pretty
nice right really nice Larry David gets
out he's feeling pretty good goes to his
car he's getting in his car someone
drives by goes hey Larry you suck and he
goes why that's all I had from that
night that's all he got from that night
was that guy one person why isn't that
crazy yeah why does that happen I'll
tell you there's it's it's called the
velcro Teflon Theory and it's it's uh
Neuroscience I guess you could say or
psychology so a negative one you suck is
like velcro it sticks to you
effortlessly this doesn't answer the why
but they've they've just you know
studied it and Teflon you know it slips
right off I say your movie is great so
the trick is when someone says you're
great to like meditate on I don't mean
like meditate I mean like think about it
for 30 seconds they say that's how long
it takes to make the velcro make the
Teflon Velcro yeah you know what my
problem was is
I
so I start uh a while ago um
stopped reading reviews of anything I
did when I wrote a book when I wrote a
book and and my wife was like hey you
got a good review of your book and I
said I don't want to read the good ones
if I read the good ones and I got to
read the bad ones yeah and they got and
I gotta I gotta value me equally yeah
and I go and I and for whatever reasons
the the negative reviews of that book
weighed so much heavier on me than the
positive ones people reviewed it people
went out of their way to write a
negative review it's really interesting
it's really interesting that like you
know I've never I've never left a I've
never left like a a negative comment
yeah what are you doing who are the
people leaving one star reviews on a
lighter on Amazon like but they're out
there I'm going to take that back I left
one negative Yelp review and the guy
lost his business what I know and I and
I and I've learned I learned from that
moment
he reached out to me he connected with
me well I I was I I did I was in
Baltimore I landed I landed I took the
red eye I landed and now it's like 10 in
the morning and I go I'm like [__]
I'm not done I'm gonna have another beer
and some lunch and I'm gonna go to sleep
I'll do my show tonight so I go across
the street to this restaurant
I say to the guy hey what's good what's
what do you recommend what's good to
drink and he goes Bud Light and the
bartender and I went but okay is there
anything getting on tap and he goes
it's right there and I went okay I said
but like do you have any local ipas and
he was like
Heineken and I went all right I'll take
a Heineken should I get a Heineken I
said local I go yeah exactly I go do you
have any uh what do you recommend for
lunch like what's really good and he
goes
turkey sandwich and I said okay and he
brings out the most Bland turkey
sandwich in the entire [__] world
and I said and is there a worse Bad
Sandwich than turkey when turkey goes
south it's so bad people yes it's
sucking the moisture from your mouth it
looks like it looks like it's so bad and
it's so and it's just a little
smattering of fries I had to ask for
like condiments like do you have any
like tomatoes or onions or lettuce or
pickles Just Turkey and bread and I go
and he goes it's gonna be extra and I
went okay I just want it to be good and
he goes you haven't even tried it and I
was like he did you haven't tried it and
so I try and I go there's nothing on
this can I get all this stuff and he's
like yeah he was such a dick that I went
on Yelp you haven't even tried it it's
something your mom says to you I bet you
could find this negative review I bet
you can find it and I leave a review on
Yelp and then literally Tuesday I'm
doing Rogan and he and Rogan says who
the [__] what kind of idiot leaves a
negative review on Yelp I go I just did
the other day and you tell the story and
I told the story and I and I and I read
the Yelp review
and then the dude that owns the
restaurant calls me he goes hey man
I've invested my life in this business
and you just [__] ruin my business
like my Yelp is destroyed everyone's
commenting negatively like I wish you
would have just come to me personally
and said hey your bartender sucks I
would have fired him no it wasn't him it
wasn't him I thought it was him it
wasn't him it was just a bad Bartender
Bartender and he goes dude I got rid of
the guy can you please get rid of your
comment and I was like well my intention
wasn't to ruin your business my
intention was I was frustrated and I
just wanted to like Yeah I wanted I
wanted to land somewhere yeah and he's
like well you got it you got it and he's
like they're coming after me man my
[__] phone's ringing people like
people are like harassing me I mean it
was bad she was right when roses started
getting big and so
so I know I I learned from that I was
like
oh I you don't you don't really benefit
you don't really benefit
sometimes like a Molotov cocktail you
throw but you throw it and then you walk
away and you have [__] it I don't give a
[__] and then sometimes you don't
realize what that effect has on people
so I stopped leaving negative comments
as a matter of fact I started leaving
positive I started finding the positive
in Yelp well that's the problem is if
people are happy this is like a thing in
business if somebody likes your product
one out of ten will write a positive
comment someone who doesn't like it it's
like one out of two we'll write a
negative comment and so if you go yeah
if you can find my Yelp reviews I wonder
if I have it on my phone I have I give I
give oh you're out there you're out
there yeah but when I like something I
Yelp it and I Yelp it really [__]
good like I really help it hang on see
if I got I'll see if I have any of my a
new mine do you want my glasses Pete
let me see
me
Bert K
uh wow that's all the things I've done I
left such a glowing [__] rope Yelp
review now I'm worried worried I don't
think I've left a negative one I'm gonna
look it up how do you do it you click me
me
uh
reviews where are your reviews
me where do you see your reviews
oh here we go two the balance brain
neurofeedback that's a neurofeedback
place here in La I just said John is the
best neurofeedback is easy comfortable
and even a little bit fun what am I a
little precocious little elf even a
little bit fun
okay you ready and sacred Chow I don't
know what that is
five years ago
hit me with yours
I said amazing food great Vibe friendly
staff tried the lentil meatloaf a
wonderful new vegan option in a great
location smiley face
embarrassing than me bitching a movie to
Ben's teller get ready to get creeped
out
it was a Monday night no no it's not as
this is a Noir the winds were whipping
sand into the street and I was starving
as I looked
don't run into the street as I looked on
Yelp everything was closed except for
the lookout Bar and Grill I have to be
honest I didn't expect much at first a
beautiful bartender named Beverly
welcomed us inside she accommodated my
weird drink Choice double Cheetos and
soda big glass no lime with three
cherries please we giggled over the
cherries no
I have a cardiologist appointment next
week
no no are you telling us are you reading
I'm and you're just you're just
you're just I have a cardiologist
appointment actually I'm trying to be
healthy but I looked at the lookout
burger and thought one more time one
more time what is this Bukowski one more
time is the phrase that ran through my
head as I took bite to the best burger
I've ever had in my entire life first
bite absolutely delicate delicious half
pound Patty with brioche bun all fresh
lettuce tomato bacon fried egg unlike a
certain place I won't mention one more
time next bite their homemade sauce
flooded my mouth my eyes rolled in the
back of my head like a shark in the
harbor next to me one more time I took a
sip of my drink
the fries fresh crisp yet soft like a
lover you'd meet on a dock on a windy
night
everything about this evening was
perfect from Beverly to the Burger to
the cocktails all I have to say to you
is one more time
one more time
you my friend have delivered today
seriously the mozzarella sticks are
pretty addictive and the burger was
legit the fish and chips are pretty good
I'm coming back wait at the end you sort
of broke down yeah yeah you're like all
narrative look how Bar and Grill look
out Bar and Grill in Oxnard look at that
word Lookout Bar and Grill Beverly's
[__] dope the the I mean I I Brenda's
self French soul food restaurant in San
Francisco [__] insane I did one I
can't remember
I did one I did one uh the one I did was
was wild was about a [__] time
I love when you but when a meal's good I
love to take that time and really
[__] oh you were feeling you were
like Beyonce in that yes you were
feeling yourself it's so much more fun
than being like this place [__] sucks
can I offer something good question yeah
was and this is really a question about
life what is that burger so good because
what's up Pete was with me
Pete was with me well yes my Candlelight
with him how great is that [__]
burger that [__] Burger is so [__]
good am I Mouse watering I swear to God
that that burger is so [__] good that
burger is so [__] good it's so good
it's so good because they really make it
it's not frozen it's fresh everything's
fresh I mean they're grinding it in the
back do they make
the burger I had the other night who the
[__] made that burger
what just oh my God I'm thinking about
Burgers now I'm having a burger for
lunch today I'm having a [__] one
more time one more time one more time
one more time uh well my queen this sort
of the answer seems to be it was a gray
Burger but how much did the fact that
you're like look I have a cardiologist
appointment next week is there anything
better than playing hooky like you broke
a rule and you and you indulged and
that's one of I used to have a joke I
never did on stage but I was like nobody
has better sex than the repressed
Christian oh yeah because you're like
I'm gonna burn in hell for this have you
ever blown uh I'm gonna blow in Hell nut
uh I've I've had the I've had this no
better
jizz and the I'm going to hell for this
jizz and that's what your burger was my
brain was my brain was always the I'm
getting AIDS and she's getting pregnant
sex that's right that's where my brains
we're about the same age I used to think
I could give myself it's from
masturbating because that's that's how
crazy I thought masturbating okay and so
I just came to terms of being gay I was
like I guess I'm gay because I can't
stop this yeah I just if that if those
are the choices this is the choice yeah
I'm gonna I'm gonna play with my dick I
can't stop playing with it I've tried
I'm Liberace I'm a Liberace of
masturbation
I can't stop giving this guy a hand job
I can't stop yeah and I would blow it if
I could oh I would have a very quiet
life if I could suck my dick
you would see me seldomly so where's
Bert sucking his dick again you know
that's all he does now
oh I would have a very quiet life I have
a friend I'll tell you I'll tell you his
name all fair who can suck his own dick
no you don't know yeah wait till I tell
you who he is and uh I said to him wait
what's it like sucking your own dick he
goes well I'll tell you this
it feels less like a [__] and more
like there's a dick in your mouth
that is truly yeah what I would imagine
yeah yeah that is that is funny okay so
we were talking about the need for
comedy I was telling you that I it's in
the movie as well like what you do
that's the other thing I don't want to
sound like your agent but the movie is
so you it like helped me
I've known you for a long time but it
like I was like oh I think I understand
you more that's what I was trying to
think about thank you yeah like that you
put some heart in it and then you had
someone explain to you in the movie like
you explain it to yourself actually
which is a very sweet scene and very
funny too
um I can't stop thinking about what he
says is our wife hot yeah yeah thank you
for not cutting that yeah and blessings
to your wife for being cool with it
because it's so funny it was well it's a
lot of that's just is it riffing yes
Jimmy it's just us riffing because you
the performance on that specifically
I'll spoil just it won't ruin it but
you're he said your young self says is
our wife hot and you're like you know
yeah when she's 50 and he's like you
married a 50 year old well she was 30
when we married her and then you're like
but you know and like you really go do
the math on camera and like you might
watch like a smokestack like why are you
making up me defend our wife like it's
so funny well we didn't have a scene
together and we wanted and at all we
didn't realize we the whole movie and
then you didn't realize during shooting
and during shooting we're like wait
Jimmy and I don't have a scene together
and they're like [__] no hot brownie
leads do it so perfectly well so so then
uh we crammed it in as we just crammed
we crammed it there's uh I could really
get into the Weeds on this I could
really like spoiler alert there's so
many interesting things that happened in
the making of this movie but and so we
realized we needed a scene and so we're
like What if there's got to be like a
flashback scene or something like what
if and so then we kind of shoehorned it
in a little bit to so that we could get
a scene in and that's not a flashback so
no it's a it's a no that's the weed
thing so the weed thing the tripping
scene yeah and it worked great and it
was just it was just on the Fly where
Jimmy was in town and we brought him out
to the because we were shooting
something else in the forest that day
and we just brought him out it was so
good and we were just like and we just I
think we talked the scene through but
one okay one of the keys of gratitude
for me is talking to however old he's
supposed to be 20. yeah 20 year old you
and when you're like you're really good
at making people laugh and like that
works and it comes from I'm not trying
to get to you know psychological here
but like if I could go back and be like
Pete you know how uncomfortable you are
you know what I mean you know how you
can't quite settle into things that
everyone else seems to settle into so
easily do you know how you can't lean in
for a first kiss and instead you just
keep you let everyone leave and you keep
making jokes and then you feel on the
couch going I should have said that
that was me I could not I could not
close a first kiss of course and so
adversely I ended up staying up all
night long with everyone buddy I used to
script I'd have a sleepover with my
friend Aaron and I'm like okay we're
starting high school tomorrow so the
eighth grade I'm like let's say you fall
in the hallway and everyone sees you
what what would you say because I was
scripting reality yeah and that's why of
course I want to write scripts and write
jokes that's what it is it's going like
what if I got to tell you what reality
was but it comes from a place of
discomfort yeah for you as well oh yeah
so to be able to tell yourself like that
works out like it's okay and by the way
you don't have to be a comedian for that
to work out that that vulnerability
attracts your partner it it develops
your skills it defines your friend group
it defines the city you live in all
these things it defines how you drive so
like your life worked out like those
things what I'm saying is you don't have
to be a famous comedian with a movie to
go like hey it's okay yeah who you are
is okay I'm older you and I'm telling
you we figured it out we found that
balance it's funny I I've I think of
that a lot about
I think more people need to know it's
okay that they're them like I mean like
we can we can very easily say that
that's what the coolest thing about uh
this generation of children with
sexuality and and finding and finding
themselves on a spectrum of sexuality
and exploring their sexuality that is
cool the fact that you're a young gay
kid I say dude only because I that I
grew up with Meat Heads but the fact
that you can be a young gay uh high
schooler as a boy and feel comfortable
in your skin it's really important yeah
but there's more people that need
there's that needs to go even further I
think there's so many people that they
hate what they are and they don't know
the right way to get to the right place
that's why I love like dudes like
you know I find that I draw a lot of
inspiration from from guys like Cameron
Haynes and David Goggins and Jeff Jessie
itzler and like these guys that do these
Ultra marathons and and things because
they they
I met a guy I met a guy in Florida and I
said and I thought he recognized me and
we were talking he was driving me to go
play tennis in a cart and I said what
podcast do you listen to anyways I don't
listen to podcasts and I said what
really and he's like yeah why do you
have one of those and I was like okay
all right I said what like you in a
comedy how many bears do you like in a
camp yeah I was like I'm waiting for him
to go I listen to your podcast right I
just thought I thought he knew me the
way he was talking and he's just a very
nice guy and I said
uh do what like what do you what do you
what are you into and he said nothing I
said well what do you listen to and he
goes nothing I said like music he goes
well I like music I said what bands he
goes what are the temperatures on the
radio and I went hold on just get in the
car and whatever's on the radio you
listen to and he's like
yeah and I was like well wait
and then I got I was like sweet you
don't have any interests
and I was like wait I go what's your
Five-Year Plan and he goes I don't know
like an ice cream store or like start a
restaurant or maybe I don't know
and I was like wait you really don't
know where you're going
and I was like [__] and then we widened
to reveal you guys just driving to a
lake like he doesn't even know where
you're driving but I was like I was like
I was like wow that's crazy like you
don't have any like you don't have any I
was um when I found comedy
I was like I got my thing yeah I got I
got my thing now having a purpose that
aligns with your talent is one of the
great keys to life and I'm a spiritual
person I would tell you at your core you
are made of peace and joy and you can
tap into that psychologically speaking
as a human being though yeah in this
plane this reality
that nothing beats something that you
feel you have to do it and when you're
good at that and you get good at that
neither of us were good you get good at
it yeah and you get like this weird
feeling of I belong and I'm being
psychologically
um delivered yeah that's yeah keep going
my agent called this morning and I said
what are you doing and it sounded so
sexy to me
he goes well I'm in my office uh French
Open semifinals are on it's [__]
great I went oh how cool to have a thing
I would have a thing yeah how cool to
get excited to go to work to turn on the
semi and finals and be like oh [__] nice
point and then get back to work and I
was like and I was like uh like if I
opened a college it wouldn't be about it
was just like helping people find their
things yeah yeah like just just let's do
a bunch of [__] today find your smile
Yeah Yeah Yeah
from What About Bob City Slickers
yeah find your smile but you know let's
talk about that guy in that golf cart
because there's a great line and I think
it's in the book of Dao uh or the doubt
itching but it's it I think about it all
the time it goes like this it the great
way meaning Enlightenment whatever you
want to call it being at peace
but the great way is not difficult for
those who have no preferences
right that that's one to just carry with
you as you walk through the woods right
yeah right now I have a preference that
this interview be interesting I have a
preference that I not go too long so you
and I can get on with all this [__] yeah
that's not actually true because I'm
just talking to you that's I can drop
those preferences and that brings me
great joy so this guy there's two ways
it can go on the surface one is this guy
is a [__] like a monk in the world
and he's just like just what's on the
radio just I'm just enjoying this trip I
I hate to say this but I doubt it
there's also a level of passivity where
it's not even like I would say be active
and deliberate and intentional in your
passivity meaning I listen to what's on
the radio because it's a reflection how
you do anything is how you do everything
and I'll just I'll enjoy any music the
music that's on in the Quiznos that's
very electric that's alive and then
there's a passivity that's almost dead
where you're like yeah I don't know man
yeah because that ice cream shop doesn't
exist I don't think so that restaurant
doesn't exist I don't think gonna happen
for a guy that does it you need and if
it does God help us it's so funny I
became the bar the no tomato bar I
didn't see the I didn't see the
I didn't see the absolute Bliss in his
life
that is
I'm certain he doesn't have Instagram
yeah he probably just gets up maybe he
smokes a bowl well that that I'm
smelling some weed on this I'd guess
yeah and but he it was really
interesting so I thought I have so much
I have so many have so many goals and I
have so many so much to that I focus on
on a daily basis
I I think about music drives me like
music music will
this morning I woke up and uh I was
watching my own stories I I I was like
since you don't post them so you're so
no no I post I posted I have someone
that posts all the other stuff like all
the you can tell which ones I did
because it's me but I'm checking to see
like if we've promoted Forest Hills if
like we've promoted Baltimore like I'm
just checking to see what's up
look at my stories and I see me come
into the office yesterday and go hey
Alexa play Go-Go's uh whatever song and
and then my Alexa hears it and my Alexa
starts playing it I went oh that's so
funny and so then I said
so if you so if I say this in my phone
it's going to play when people are
watching their stories when they wake up
if they're watching it and then their
Alexa is going to pick so I said I get
to pick what song we all listen up to
that for the people to follow me you're
the World's DJ and I was like and I was
like rambling gambling ma'am and then I
just [__] let that move music try me
and I thought to myself today and then
immediately I I get I jump in the pool I
walk out of my room playing listen to
that music jump in the pool go and talk
to Leanne my agent calls and he's like
I'm watching this and I thought of that
kid and I thought I wonder how he wakes
up I wonder what I wonder if he just
well that's what I'm talking about
intentionality even if you are going to
be a low a zero footprint monk yeah that
Monk Is brimming with intentionality why
am I being quiet why am I not on
Instagram why am I whatever it is so you
can be very deliberate uh David Goggins
or you can be a very deliberate technod
Han but intentionality I think is a deal
breaker I think if you don't have it you
can't just kind of like smoke a bowl
into uh passivity I that's different
from what yeah uh like a a deeply dipped
in person would be doing I think I could
be completely full of [__] I don't know
I know I I I wish I could do I have a
hard time just sitting I like I do I do
my gratitudes in the morning yeah uh
usually before my my trainer comes I'll
try to get outside if it's light and and
just let the sun in my face and do my
gratitudes and then but this morning I
wrote them down uh what Cuba yeah oh no
no I got it from uh oh the sunlight in
the face is it oh no that's Superman
that's Superman yeah that's Superman my
gratitude I got from uh Rob Dyrdek okay
because he does I do that too he and so
the my gratitude one of the Gratitude
says uh one of them today was
uh I do I do write by others and like
meaning I want the best for everyone
yeah and I was like that's a cool thing
that I know that about myself like I
don't wish bad on anybody and I
well that's that's what comes through in
your movie and talking to you now and
it's funny when I did your cooking show
I got really hooked like almost obsessed
I've Loved Jonathan Kite now who
Jonathan Kite oh yeah yeah I'm sorry
follow him he's got a great podcast
yeah no I didn't mean to by the way you
introduced me to him no you follow him
on Instagram now he's [__] hilarious
keep going I'm sorry Jonathan is
fantastic in fact would you send me a
reminder we've been meaning to have him
on the pot I don't know why that hasn't
happened yet Annie please thank you
Katie I I got do you remember I was
really like honing in that you were
telling me that you were kind of
stressed about your life yeah yeah and I
was over here going like you make this
much money a weekend and you know what
it was is I was like if you can't do it
what hope do any of us have meaning do
our lives just keep expanding meaning
okay I'm gonna make up I don't want
anybody in your business we'll just make
up numbers and be like you do make a
thousand dollars uh to do a show and
there's four weekends in a month and you
get four thousand dollars so you rent an
apartment that's uh fifteen hundred
dollars and the rest are expenses and a
little bit of savings then your your
ticket comes in let's say now you're
making a hundred thousand dollars but
then you get an apartment that's two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars you
know what I'm saying like expand
everything expands and I do this too but
I hold out and maybe I'm deluding myself
that I'm like yeah but next train that
comes in will cool it it's it's like the
cowboys that go one last Heist and then
I'll retire oh oh okay yeah sometimes I
feel like uh I feel like the uh blow the
movie Blow yes Johnny Depp goes in and
goes all right one last hit and then I
get money to retire and I get my and I
I've said that actually I've said that a
number of times yeah I've invested in a
few companies uh and and uh we they're
doing very well and we were driving over
the hill to do a podcast and I said man
if these companies do well and I can
sell them and I can get out yeah uh I'm
done like I'm done and they're like what
do you mean you're done I go they go you
mean you're done touring I go no no I
just I just won't talk towards hard and
like wait what about the business we
just started a business a birdie board
Productions where we're producing stuff
and we're marketing we're doing
marketing and social media for other
Comedians and I said no I'll do that
like I'll come into the office and do
that and they're like well hold on will
you not do movies you go no I'll do
movies and they're like but you're not
done I think there's this yeah I think
there's an imaginary Finish Line in my
head with a number that a number has to
Define and I thought I thought I knew
the number I really thought I knew the
number Like Walter White yeah yeah I
thought I knew the number and then I
just keep pushing that ahead going let's
get a little more let's do this let's do
this let's do
fully loaded and then and then let's do
our our fall tour and then let's go in
and we'll shoot a movie in January we'll
shoot a TV show in in March
and then I'll do one more tour and then
I just start like I'm supposed to take
um seven weeks off uh right after we do
fully loaded I'm supposed to take seven
weeks off
and in that process I have committed to
um
oh I don't imagine it's seven weeks
completely completely off in those seven
weeks one of them I was gonna go to a uh
a silent Retreat I haven't had plans I
was gonna do silent read there's like a
like a rehab facility like that where
you don't drink you don't do drugs you
you stay it's in Malibu it's like it's
not like a inpatient or anything but
it's uh you're just really healthy it's
a reset and you go like on Hikes and you
work out yeah it's maybe it's like fat
camp but like yeah but it's it's no
drugs and alcohol and I was just I
wanted to go there it's like 10 days I
wanted to go there and [__] reset I
wanted to do a lot of things I've signed
up to produce a disc golf tournament
I'm producing a special for [__] I'm
producing a special I signed up to
produce a TV show like I've signed up
for everything and I just I just cannot
and I'm with you and I think humanity is
with you so if the issue isn't money and
I'm saying let's figure this out
together please when I when I did your
cooking show I I was kind of going like
why can't he figure this out I want us
to figure this out you know if it's not
money
what is it what are we really missing
like what would help us slow down you
know what I'm saying
is it is it the juice the chase like
there's a there's a little bit of
there's a little bit
I feel like do you ever do you ever see
I I growing up in Florida one of the big
things that I always do grow up every
day I get in my pool
I try to swim back and forth holding my
breath underwater it's just a real it's
like a stupid Florida test of like can
you I do it with my girls
I I was also a soft boy I'm a soft boy
but I mean like I was the softest boy
the little Butterball turkey in the swim
group and that was the big kids
challenge yeah like I loved it I feel
like something about my insulation
helped me hold my breath longer or I
needed it more than the skinny [__] I
don't know what it was but I'm with you
yeah I still I have a pool I do that I
still love it and sometimes I will
get down to one side and I'll go I still
got more in me yeah and I'll turn around
and give it a go I know one good push
more time and then yeah and so I feel
and it's that one more time one more hit
dude One More tour because right now I'm
in a place where I go so I I did I'm
doing an arena tour I'm doing only
arenas for the whole year and then I go
well I mean not like
I'm being very honest right now and I
know that people may uh sometimes use my
honesty as weakness but I go so do I do
I do it do I maybe if it gets clapped
[Laughter]
once it's on Instagram I'm out yeah I
can't vouch for the fans there
I go do I do
another what I mean what do I do another
Arena tour I mean like or dude dude go
back to do theaters and and if you do
theaters
are your money's gonna go down are you
cool with your money going down do you
do a club tour and do clubs because then
if you do clubs you got to get rid of
the tour bus but because it just isn't
cost effective and you're because you're
there for the weekend
like what like and then I was like so
wait like I don't mean this I don't mean
this
arrogant but like we're the place in
comedy all of us where we're really
seeing Uncharted territories guys like
me never did Arena tours guys like uh
Chappelle live in arenas you know it's
it's weird like
uh I don't know where uh where to go
with this and I don't know what to do
and I don't know I don't know like I
mean I'm super hungry like that's the
other part is like like Ali Wong like
the great comics of Our Generation Ali
Wong and Sebastian and [__] Bill Burr
and all the groups
um but all the great comics of Our
Generation kind of take a lot of time
off yeah like and and but I was never
them I was a guy who did every [__]
weekend I did every weekend that's what
I do I do stand up I do it every [__]
week but that's what I would want for
you is I want you to get the update to
your phone the phone that is burnt yeah
that I have
you know what I mean I feel like I've
updated how I see you and I you know
this is a little therapy-ish I suppose
but I think the way we all see you now
we're not even taking into account all
of those like shadows and Echoes that
you're still holding on to like you know
what I'm saying like you're still seeing
the guy that needs to hustle and break
and I'm over here going like Ali Wong it
baby she I see her tour dates they don't
give me a panic attack sometimes the
idea that you're going every weekend
yeah I go every weekend I go every
weekend but what is Ellie told me one
time she goes you know hey by the way
I'm sorry Ali if I'm share our secrets
but she goes
you're on tour every [__] weekend I
said yeah and she goes it doesn't go
away and in my head I was like it
[__] definitely does like I've like
I've seen it go away for people I want
to enjoy it as long as I can I want you
saying that to me I can't know if this
is true but you also can't know if yours
is true meaning we're both predicting
the future which is stupid neither of us
can know but I am over here going like I
think the foundation of your house is a
lot more sturdy than you may think it is
and that's just a loving word keep going
out every weekend do it like I I think
you're an energizing joy-giving person
but I'm also like
I think you could
just psychologically relax I don't think
they're going to go away you know I I
don't think they're going to go away but
I feel like I feel like if I get out of
the cycle of doing specials like right
now I'm doing a special roughly every 18
months and they're each doing better
than the one before them and and then I
feel like if I'm if I get out of the
cycle of creating material I might get
lazy and then I remember watching great
Comics kind of fall apart when they just
stopped the fire wasn't there I hear
what you're saying and and I I'll say
this from just from my perspective
Razzle Dazzle was the best thing I've
ever done and I went and then I go
I'm in this place where I go what do we
learn from it how do we move forward how
do we do something better you know I I I
there's I've drawn inspiration from a
lot of great comics and I I what I've
noticed in great Comics is they keep
putting out specials and they challenge
themselves to do better and so I go so
if if I'm gonna do that
I'm not I don't know I just keep going
I'm not I can't take a year off like I'm
supposed to take seven weeks off and I'm
like I can do sets in the city right and
then it's like well that's kind of the
idea is like we're gonna just take some
time off a lot of this is very black and
white though it's seven weeks offer
every weekend like and I say this just
as your friend I either drink or I don't
drink at all I know but yeah and I'm not
I'm saying this it takes one to no one
that's attic mentality we're very black
and white oh yeah no oh yeah no that's
not me pointing a finger that's no no no
no no I'm oh I'm you don't need to point
fingers I just was like I quit drinking
that's and that's what we do that's what
I do we go uh quit drinking and then I
go I quit drinking and then someone goes
do you want a glass of wine I go I'm not
drinking and they go but it's a glass of
wine they go hey guys we can do this not
do this right that's something yeah like
and you're that way with comedy yeah but
my question for you and my question for
me is is there a bird who goes out once
a month or twice a month every other
weekend why even go out at all
like that's what I I literally you know
that's a very [__] accurate uh
accurate assessment what is the voice of
that thought though I am not enough I'm
bad I'm lazy I'm wasting a gift this is
an opportunity I'm in the candy shop I
should eat as many handfuls of Skittles
as I can because they're going to
realize I'm a fraud maybe which one
probably the fraud part but yeah people
are going to realize like he wasn't that
good it's really interesting yeah I mean
listen I know that that these aren't
these aren't supposed to stay as a comic
like no Comics talking this way and I
and I I'm aware of that and I realize I
the the exposure I'm showing my neck in
this but like I I I have to work harder
than everyone else to be even
in the same conversation I think like I
have to work twice as hard to be as good
as
uh sagura because I can say him because
he's my best friend Fat Tom I have to be
I have to work twice as hard to be as
good as he is and I have to work twice
as hard in clubs and and on the road to
be as as good like like as as
the as the as the people I want to
Aspire to right I look I look up to
everyone I don't know what that is I had
this syndrome when I was a kid when I
always thought everyone was older than
me everyone I remember hanging out I
remember hanging out with this kid at
tennis camp his name was Jay and I was
like he was the coolest [__] dude
cool as [__] a little shorter than
everyone else
it's older than me he could break dance
and we were cool he was cool as [__]
and and he was working me a little bit
like he like I had some money in the in
the comment in the commissary but like
at the static credit I'd credit a snack
bar and uh I would get him uh Mentos uh
the The Freshman the fruit no the fruit
yeah the fruit what were the fruit ones
are they still called Mentos are they
called yeah they were they were Mentos
the French so good I get them the Mentos
I'd get them a pack I get myself a pack
I get a cheeseburger and a Sprite and
he'd be like okay spray I'd give him a
Sprite I'd put it on him he's an older
kid right he's the coolest kid in the
camp one day we're sitting there and
we're eating and I go I don't know him
very well but I'm like I'm like hanging
out with him because I want to be around
the coolest kid and I go where do you go
to school and he's like uh Dale Mabry or
whatever and I go uh where's that he was
like over there I go wait how old are
you and he's like I'm 10 and I go I'm
12.
and he was like no I'm a [__] child
I'm like
of your [__] 10 and he was like yeah
he was aren't you 10 and I go no I'm
[__] 12 and he goes were you hanging
out with me for and I was like I don't
know Jay I don't know I don't know
and I was like I just thought he was
older than I was I think that all the
time yeah yeah yeah little imposter
thing but I'm also you know what to give
you a compliment not to enable but to
not to look at it from another way I do
see a a Zeal and a zest you know what I
mean I know what you're talking about
when you wanna you don't want to pawn
because it gets stagnant and it gets all
green and he goes you want to be a
Rushing River uh a hundred percent I
want an activity I want activity I want
sound I want Tranquility I want to be a
Rushing River I do not want to be a pond
that is that is a very very very
accurate assessment what is it yeah I
guess what I the Trap I fell into last
time was assuming because I tour once a
month and I love it
but I'm different I'm a different boy
I'm an introvert yeah you know what I
mean I I know I'm very extrovert I'm an
extroverted introvert and I really can I
tell you all I think about when you say
that when you say that yeah all right
I immediately say Pete come on the road
with me let's do this fall [__] Arena
tour I'll pay you solid money and then I
guarantee you when you see how [__]
good you are at the end of it yeah
you're gonna go I'm out every [__]
week I'm out every because I know how
good I am and it's because I have to
work as hard as I am I'm not blowing
smoke up my own ass yeah I know you're
better than I am and so I know that if
you worked as hard as I worked you'd be
[__]
unfucking stoppable like I did it to
mbag I brought in bag out on the road
with me and I realized
I realized just how good I wasn't
because I was like oh he is naturally
one of the funniest human beings in the
world he was working in Arena and he was
doing crowd work to sections he was
doing crowd work to sections he was so
[__]
he was so [__] amazing I know what
you mean I watched David tell I took
David tell out to do those ballparks and
and David tell I mean this is like this
is what I this is why I look up to Great
Comics because I you watch them and your
mind's blown David tell
had had memorized the landscape behind
him what the people were looking at in
the cityscape behind him yeah and was
using it as callbacks wow and I was like
I've been doing outdoor Arenas
never once thought yeah you should look
at the city no that's a savant the
Savant yeah I here you're making you're
highlighting what I think the difference
is the juice that you get from like
crush and growing almost like a
corporation I don't even I mean you're
like Nike you're like okay we had a
great year let's have an even better yet
yeah I am like that I get it and you
didn't make that up by the way you sort
of inherited as did I that Mythos that
that story from our culture and that's
your last your last is it your last HBO
special yeah that's all over Tick Tock
and Instagram right now I believe so
it's in my algorithm all the time yeah
you clicked it
dude it is I am so blown away by your
ability
Blown Away by your insights your comedic
instincts but just how [__] funny you
are oh thanks man and look I I say this
all the time I don't I
uh I was listening a group of guys [__]
on a comic and I was just like what are
you doing yeah I was like why are you
looking behind yeah comedy cancer yeah
what the [__] are you doing okay I was
like I was like you guys ready your
goddamn mind yeah first of all look
ahead look in front of you what you're
like you're like driving in New York
traffic going what's behind me yeah
you're the [__] energy is ahead of
you right [__] sit and watch
Chappelle sit and watch Patton sit and
watch Sarah Sarah's new hour that's on
HBO right HBO Max right now is [__]
brilliant edit that out but yeah
like [__] [__] I love that sit and
watch Rogan I go dude I I watch Rogan
when I go to do the comedy Mothership I
do my spot and the little boy the other
day I run over to the big one I run over
and I watch him and Leanne's like what
are you doing let's talk I go ah we're
watching Rogan and I was like if if I
get a chance
to watch great comedy that's what I want
to talk about like if you if you're like
what would you want to talk about with
comedy I mean I'm not gonna you want to
talk about what you like yeah you're
positive Yelp yeah like I like Matt Rife
is killing it right now yeah he's
killing it yeah he's killing it the guy
[__] did an announce video with
Ashton Kutcher that went viral and he
sold out a [__] tour that is top to
buy I go I go that's what I want I want
to talk about the the people killing it
yeah that's where I focus and celebrate
you know like the great Comics what I
was gonna say was and I get everything
you're saying like you know you're
lighting my fuse I get it I love comedy
I love improving I just filmed my my new
special last weekend I'm thrilled uh
bird produced it which I'm like he kind
of walked me in he's hard to get a
special he helped me out
um but the the weird it's not weird the
different game I'm playing is I love
seeing how little I can feed it
there's there's something to that yeah
there's something to that because I I
love that people where I live don't like
they don't think of me as a comedian I
love that I'm around I'm at the [__]
dance recital I'm not saying you're so
funny by the way do people know where
you live yeah I live in Ohio as soon as
can I tell you how my brain works tell
me
I I can't stop thinking about work I
cannot stop thinking about work when you
said oh or no high I said you know
I'm going to be an Oxnard for seven
weeks is because we have a house there
I'm gonna be an Oxford and immediately I
went hey do you want to do we should do
like a residency at the inbox at the
Liberty Live yeah let's do like Sunday
nights or Let's do let's do Sunday
nights or do Monday night something an
off night yeah well sell tickets we'll
promote it and we're gonna have a fun
[__] night just me and you
co-headline we'll just we'll just bring
yeah immediately that's my brain but I
think only about work and there's a way
that me in the past has been like let's
fix that and I'm actually over here
going like
you're you're uh it's beautiful you're
an engine and it's running and it's
great and that's life there's a lot of
life when we go back to the big lime you
know that you really are it's my
favorite toast yeah that's my favorite
you're a big to life I love to life and
I go [__] yeah man yeah oh we only get
to do it once what are we doing not
getting into [__] and not getting like
not getting finding our passion yeah and
when I say I'm not even joking when we
talk about that kid with the ice cream
shop and we talk about opening a school
where people can find the stuff they're
into I think I got so [__] lucky to
find comedy because I don't ever feel
like I'm working and I work yeah I work
literally
6 a.m until 7 00 P.M every night I was
thinking about the people I'm not trying
to be funny I'm not looking down my nose
on anybody but somebody's job is to
castrate pigs you know what I mean and
that's that's a like my worst day would
be their best day and I'm only saying
that for gratitude and perspective
that's a job and sometimes I'm like you
know the crowd didn't really yeah shut
the [__] up shut the [__] up you could
be clipping Pig nuts uh I I worked with
a guy who had to castrate uh cows I mean
and he loved it
he loved it he had his Granddaddy's
knife and he had it I swear to God he
had his Granddaddy's knife that has had
been castrating cows with the same knife
the same knife and the blade was so worn
down that it was the knife in a thin
blade this is my Granddaddy's knife and
that cow kicked me in the jaw as they
cast her I tried to help him because we
were doing for a TV show and he loved
his [__] he loved doing it and he
wanted to show me how much fun it was
and I could not get into it I was like
you couldn't get into it I was like dude
this is breaking my heart
this episode is brought To Us by our
friends at p-y-m choose what is p-y-m
prepare your mind Pym choose can help
manage feelings of stress anxiety and
overwhelm it's been wonderful for when
I'm feeling worried stressed out or as
well like to say when we have a bee in
our belly you just chew two of these
delicious naturally flavored no sugar
added chews and in minutes for real for
real you start to feel more centered
calm and in control I love these guys so
much that when I first tried them I
thought it was too good to be true I got
a subscription for myself and I bought
some for my mom and my brother just so
happy to find something that helps with
anxiety and stress that is natural
non-addictive non-psychoactive I like
taking it at the start of my day ease me
into whatever it is I'm trying to do
sometimes I get a little stressed when I
just want to face my inbox or start
rolling into the work and sometimes I
take it at the end of the day to help me
relax and melt away the stress that I
accumulated while I was working when I
was out with people how Pym choose are
comprised of proven amino acid complexes
and adaptogens that help support your
brain and your body's ability to
organically meaning help your body do
what it can do on its own support your
ability to manage and tolerate stress
anxiety and overwhelm I take it every
day along with their mood magnesium
which helps me relax as well and also
helps me sleep it's very effective in
helping me fall asleep faster and sleep
throughout the night and wake up Less in
the night and wake up feeling refreshed
and rested mood magnesium is incredible
has the three magnesiums with the most
evidence to support their effects on
stress and sleep and one percent of
their profits go towards a mental health
non-profit so help your body and your
mind fight off stress and overwhelm and
sleep more deeply with our friends at
Pym go to you can pym.com weird and use
promo code weird for 15 off that's you
like y o u can the
c-a-n-p-ym.com weird for 15 off and show
your support of the show we're also
brought To Us by our friends at Caraway
one of the simplest and smallest things
that have added so much value to our
lives is cooking together as a family
and with a four-year-old we've noticed
that when our daughter is involved in
the preparation she's so much more
likely to eat what we cook and even try
new things Val and I are in love with
the best looking best cooking new cook
and bakeware from Caraway No nasty
chemicals which is huge easy to clean
which is huge so much of the time you
don't want to cook because you don't
want to clean and they are absolutely
beautiful and fun to use whether you're
into spring cleaning or just about to do
some anytime cleaning their thoughtfully
designed sets and complementary storage
makes getting and staying organized
easier than ever and you can now save 10
off the full Suite of Caraway products
from their internet famous cookware to
their newly launched food storage set
caraway's high quality ceramic coating
kitchenware is free three of PTFE such
as Teflon lead cadmium and other toxic
materials to know your cooking safe and
Caraway kitchenware comes in a variety
of chic Shades and sets include
complementary easy access storage
solutions they're ceramic it's naturally
slick surface surface means minimal oil
or butter for slide off the pan eggs and
easy cleaning and over 4 40 000 not four
forty thousand people have raved about
their Caraway kitchen now it's time to
try it for yourself visit
carawayhome.com weird to take advantage
of this limited time offer for 10 off
your next purchase that's
carawayhome.com weird it's exclusive
just to Weirdos carawayhome.com weird
and use code weird at checkout Caraway
non-toxic cookware made Modern
all right everybody back to Bert Crusher
buddy
as horrible as it is if it's gonna
happen and it seems like it's going to
happen yeah I'd at least want it to be a
guy going like I love it gotta get in
that nut chop flow yeah and then he
looked they love the love that I was a
city boy yeah come on now hold him down
come on man hold him down Neil deGrasse
Tyson when he did the Pod talked about a
guy with a cigarette and he was just he
was killing cows I know this is dark but
he just seemed like he was a pig and
[__] just kind of like executing cows I
met a dude in Denver who put down dogs
at the pound and he loved it and he
loved it why I haven't I you know I I
was friends I hope he doesn't hear this
because I was friends with him
and you're like I think this is over and
I was like I don't think I can be
friends with him anymore because it
really broke my heart and he's like no
man that no one's gonna take care of
that dog no one does and then I come in
I give him a minute
and then everything's great for them
it's done yeah the ease I was like this
is really sad it tells you a little bit
about that person's potentially their
Cosmic perspective maybe you consciously
are unconscious I heard Jen Kirkman one
time and I apologize again if I'm not
paraphrasing this properly sensitive
because I don't I because I speak so
[__] recklessly yeah and so quick
that I never talking like it's just you
and me yeah and then and then all of a
sudden Rogan's like what are you talking
about [__] TV time out and I'm like I
don't know Joe I thought you said that
by the way Joe just used me as the
example of a frumpy dump my brother said
it was um the guy from Blink 182 Trey
Parker
okay let's not get hung up on that Trey
Barker Travis Barker Travis Barker sorry
everybody Travis Barker's [__] skinny
Minnie he's a skinny mini but he wasn't
it wasn't that uh Joe was saying
um and my brother clipped it and sent it
to me which is so funny it didn't bother
me yeah I liked it it was fun to talk to
my brother about it we ripped on it but
he was talking about when he talked when
Joe talks to Elon Musk he's like I feel
like I'm Pete Holmes racing Usain Bolt
that's a really that's a [__] great
analogy though because I can see
hold on were we supposed to wear short
shorts I like there's you would pick
that apart that is it I am wearing dress
shoes for some reason do we I can hear
you at the thing do we go on three or do
we go on one and then you hear the gun
you go it was the gun
is I actually it's a good analogy by Joe
I I'm a I'm I enjoy the show I'm a fan I
was just like what fun that I got to be
the example oh yeah that's fun that
you're in is I like that you're that he
even said yeah he goes no disrespect no
he loves you he loves you
let me ask you this I have a joke that I
sometimes do I go Joe Rogan is such a
man he looks like the men's room symbol
do you think he would like that or would
he be like I think he'd like it hey no
that's because I'm just saying he's a
man like look at the broad shoulders and
the circle head it looks like a
weightlifter no it does that's a good I
think it's okay because I literally said
devel I never do this but I was like
well that hurt my career
Joe's dude Joe is a is comedian first
that's what I first that's what I first
and he like he you can't you know
there's no okay yeah you can't I like
that we aired this here oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah Joe's a comedian first I
remember I had a joke about UFC and I go
don't you think it would be better if
they had to [__] each other in the ass
and he was like huh I go never mind he
goes wait wait what are you talking
about I don't think you're like this
joke here's why and I said because
you're in the UFC he goes I'm a comedian
first tell me the joke and I went don't
you think the fights would be better if
one guy had to hold the other guy down
and [__] him in the ass to win and he
was like we don't get it and I go how
hard would you fight and then he started
laughing and I went oh my God that's
right you are a comedian first how hard
would you fight really hard how hard
would you find yeah deeply if you knew
your ass was on the line also I think
I've tried to make the joke that there's
only one body smell this is never gonna
make it to the stage ooh interesting
there's only one body smell so the way
your dick smells is the way your armpits
smell it's the way everything smells and
so these guys can smell each other
they're getting close they're wrestling
I'm saying the ancient Greeks were right
let's get naked let's wrestle but let's
take it all the way to the period at the
end of the sentence which is hardcore
[__] yeah we're over here going like
nah just punching just punching any
ancient Greek meaning you and me if we
were born in that time would go to a UFC
fight they would fight we're in robes
holding goblets would be like and now
commence with the [__]
I would be like here here
that was a good opening to what we're
all here for the deep penetration my
favorite part of that would be one guy
being unconscious and the other guy
having to try to get his dick hard in
front of everyone else going like hey
give me a second you can't get him he
can't get a boner yeah yeah and then he
just sucks his own dick like your friend
what was his name again I'm just kidding
so
the thing I was saying about Rogan is
like he you know the engine this goes
back to the very beginning of the
conversation he did he did got the man
show and then he did the he did the
Carlos Mencia thing where he kind of
stuck his not kind of but he stuck his
nut on the lines for all the comics and
and fair use of your own [__]
material and he got punished for that
The Comedy Store kicked him out really
you didn't know that I didn't know he
was doing it he got kicked out of The
Comedy Store for a while isn't that
funny just how things shift didn't
change and so he had to reinv I mean he
is if you feel down about yourself if
you're like I don't have a shot in this
world I don't have anything to hang my
hat on look at Joe Rogan now granted he
had money he could have just retired but
he was kicked out of the place he loved
more than anything The Comedy Store and
he was and he was kind of had to take a
little bit of a TV time out from The Man
Show the fear Factor's gone he'd already
done the sitcom he's known now as the
Fear Factor guy right and he [__] sat
in that office of his and and said I'm
not I'm gonna win I'm gonna put so I'm
sure it's my phone just getting [__]
slacks he goes I'm gonna I'm going to
win I'm gonna reassess and I'm gonna
redirect my career and I'm gonna start a
podcast and and no one knew it like I
draw inspiration from that dude because
yeah he never he never
got counted out he was like no I'm
standing back up what's next
consistently in his career yeah even
when even when you can go even into like
the pandemic times when people like [__]
this guy CNN's trying to attack him and
he's like I'm not out and still he's
just pushing forward that's like I I
draw inspiration from dudes like that I
draw inspiration as well from somebody
who is speaking their truth you know he
is not he has he has an authentic yeah
he speaks out of Integrity I I he never
doesn't speak out of Integrity it's
Robert McKee the guy who wrote story
yeah his definition of a hack he doesn't
mean it in the comedian way this is one
of my favorite definitions
please keep going this I read this in
that silver book I read this uh over and
over and over and over again well now I
really hope I get it right it's also in
the war of art he quotes it which is
where I got it that's war of art is what
I'm thinking about okay yeah that's a
silver book right the story is silver I
think I I think it's a straight up
silver oh really oh book I got was
silver with a red thing I think you were
given an award sounds like you were
reading a Peabody Award I'm not I'm not
positive but it says the definition of a
hack is someone who thinks they can
predict what an audience wants they're
thinking about that first and then they
try to reverse engineer and give it to
them and I was with the marketplace is
dictating exactly they want to sell it
so they're going like I think that's why
I said the machine right
you didn't just make a movie because you
could make a movie there's nothing worse
than a video game based on a movie
almost always historically because that
video game is being manufactured to be
released around the time the movie is
released not when the game is done yeah
now when the game was done when the
muses got quiet and stopped telling you
how to make the Matrix Game it just got
released because that's when it had to
be released and it [__] sucks because
it didn't need to be it was a marketing
play that's a hack move you're right and
what I I find inspiring about Joe
is that he's out there going like I'm
not making any choices based on fear I'm
I'm gonna I'm going to explore and
people won't like and then people will
like and by the way I'm not an expert on
all the things he said I have to be
nervous and I'm not enticing anything
I'm just saying I like people and I'm
drawn to people that are going like I'm
curious about this let's talk about it
and aren't going like it's it doesn't
it's not safe to talk about this or
whatever it's the other thing about him
and and this is you know it's really
hard because not everyone understands
this but he when we say he's a comedian
first he is also just a comedian like he
is so like I mean I I he texts me we
he's obsessed with statins right now
like you know what statins like Islands
no statins though
the heart medication cholesterol
medication what is it why would you be
obsessed with that who knows who [__]
knows people what is it what does it do
do you have a cardiologist appointment
no I I know that I'm on statins because
it lowers your cholesterol well you take
it yeah I take statins but it's not like
something like a Statin lowers your
cholesterol but it also gives you like
vivid dreams and you can tell you I'll
tell you by the way I know this because
we've talked to Joe and I've now
listened to the podcast he did with this
great doctor talked all about statins
I've talked about the [__] big Pharma
leaning in trying to make money selling
their products to cardiologists who sell
their products yeah I now know way more
than I should know but I do know that
when I started taking statins they said
we want to really check your liver every
other month because they statins can
[__] with their liver yeah and that and
that statins can shorten your lifespan
where they think it's expanding your
lifespan and by the way I'm speaking
yeah I did the research I don't know
what the [__] I'm talking about to quote
Penn Gillette if anyone watching makes a
medical decision based on a comedian on
a podcast yes this is his joke he goes
you deserve to die that's his joke his
joke I'm not saying that but but
Joe is is like he's a guy who gets into
something gets to be in his Bonnet and
he starts doing the research and he's
passionate about [__] and oh like it's
one of my it's like where we're talking
about your agent watching the games like
yeah we just love having a Passion I
loved learning everything I could about
poker remember when poker was so popular
yes I loved getting into that whole
world the only thing that exists is
learning like oh two seven off suit is
the worst handling and that's what
comedy is comedy it's like a so my
station my foot my thing for uh like I
it's it's once again I go back to the
kid with the ice cream store I like it
doesn't have an accident by the way if
he does I'll eat [__] I'll happily eat
that [__] sandwich that exists I'll be
like lahime what if what if he's
listening to this and he goes wait first
of all I do listen to podcasts I didn't
know you're talking about all right
we're in the clear he doesn't listen to
podcasts yeah we're in the clear and
then he's like secondly I [__] make
ice cream bro I'm not just some [__]
yeah like my passion is [__] ice
cream like we're starting to talk to
some [__] goes what podcast do you
listen to that's right he's like hey man
maybe yeah I have a little bit of
dignity and I don't share my whole life
with everyone [__] and I'm like but
uh that is great the I go back to that
kid and I think
the oh [__] I don't even know what I was
gonna say anymore the kill the ice cream
store we're talking about Joe we're
talking about uh oh I get into so I get
into stuff like really get into stuff
statins and and not statins I wish I
could get into like smart stuff like
history I'm really into history I'm
really into
um I get like this is gonna sound crazy
but like when we wanted to get a dog I
really got into researching dogs yeah no
it would be so much fun it's a if you're
back after after a show get in your
hotel bed and just get on the iPad and
start flipping through dogs and going
like that's a good dog let me research
oh don't you know what to say about
um like pornography is it's not
pornography it's it's the search bubble
that you get in it's when you're looking
for the thing that turns you on the most
right so it's not actually the [__] I
know I'm saying it in kind of a funny
way but it's true it's not actually the
orgasm it's the 30 minutes that you
spent trying to find something so
similarly it's not the car it's not even
the dog blog Seinfeld has this great
line where he goes it's not the movie
It's the drive to the movie that that's
that sacred place where you know you're
going to see it it's not the vacation
yeah it's not it's the getting ready for
the vacation that's right it's not you
know it's not this conversation it's you
it's like I liked that I was looking
forward to it as I was driving in you
know that's life and I I know I use
pornography but like I like to kind of
let people off the hook and say you're
not just obsessing about something silly
you're actually creating this bubble
around you where nothing else exists and
there's nothing like pinpoint Focus like
bringing your attention even to
something stupid it might it might be a
video game when I play uh I'm playing
the new Zelda game when I play that I'm
only thinking about one thing and it can
be I'm gonna say I'm gonna say I'm gonna
say it I'm Rogan I don't care it's
meditative it can be uh I I I'm gonna
credit Doug Benson I'm not sure if this
is what he said uh and I'm
I'm just gonna I apologize Doug if this
is not really we're sorry John Kirkman
we're sorry
she said something about the capital
stormers made sense and that that I
don't know okay I'm joking I'm trying to
think of something totally different
no Jen said that she didn't ask to be
born uh at one point I thought that was
crazy I never thought about I never
thought about that I thought about it as
a gift never a curse and then I realized
oh there's a lot of people in this world
that never asked to be born that's like
Joe De Rosa don't forget what you were
gonna say uh about who is he about to
quote
Doug has a great uh Judy Rose has a
great joke where he goes Jesus died for
your sins and he goes I didn't ask him
to which I think is so funny it's
interesting I actually think Jen is
articulating the central point that the
ego would like to make which is I'm here
and it's not my fault and I actually
think it's artistically honest yeah but
it's not to me I I would shift that I
would go like
uh I I don't find that to be a helpful
world view I I don't think she's saying
it is either but it is honest it can be
honest like Doug Benson said the thing
he likes about roller coasters is that
you're forced to be present you're
forced to be in that moment there's it's
really hard to think about your taxes
when you're [__] Free Falling that's
what ramdas says he goes when you're in
a car accident chances are you aren't
horny yeah and but that's how and he
also says when you're reading a book
when you start reading a book you can
hear the clock the second hand of the
clock ticking
then you get into the book and it fades
away so what is consciousness and this
is what I'm saying about your guy the
golf cart ice cream shop guy
focusing attention and doing nothing
deliberately can be an incredibly
powerful thing it can actually change
reality you'll stop hearing a sound but
that's very different from just getting
I don't know what that guy was doing but
getting baked and listening to
whatever's on the radio
you're gonna drink this
what's up it's magic mine shake it
it's got a little bit of caffeine it's
got neutropics and adaptogen so it helps
with stress helps you think Joe loves it
they just sent him a big case but you
would love it
um but we just we hit that 90 minute low
and I was like this will help us this
will carry us through the end I already
had mine it tastes good that's a good
thing you're gonna love it uh where were
we oh you were about to quote Doug you
already did I did all right yeah I did
where were we
uh we were talking we were talking about
no we started talking about the uh what
I was about to do The Man Show you want
to finish that no I called Tom and I
said hey do you ordered the band show
with me and he went nope
and he was like why would we do their
show he's like let's just do our own
show
that's a great Rick Rubin says he
doesn't hang up his gold platinum
records and he goes why would I try to
do something I've done before why would
I surround myself with the burden of
hitting and hitting a benchmark that
I've already hit yeah he's like blank
walls it's like you there is no Razzle
Dazzle you're just here today you're
just going for the next one yeah I try
not to look back and just go what's next
yeah that's the fun part it's when you
when you talk about like um
the it's not the vacation it's the
getting ready for the vacation plan and
vacation the texting back and forth yeah
uh
I had a I have a friend I have a friend
I can say she'll never hear it it's kind
of weird but the co-star of my movie the
uh
uh Eva babic is she the Russian yeah
she's great she's awesome and she's a
really interesting person a really
interesting person she said to me um
I was talking about like just
fantasizing I go you know what if we did
like a what if we did like a a cast
um a cast like party and like we are
like what if if I make a lot of money we
did like a cast party and then we all
went to like somewhere to to go like
what would be fun to go
and I and she goes well I know where I'd
want to go and I said well I know where
I'd want to go and she said
say it at the same time and randomly we
both said the Canary Islands wow and
then she goes wait that's crazy she goes
she was what if we went but we went on
the wrong weekend and everyone else went
on the same weekend and I went she goes
what would we do and I was like I don't
know it's like this woman was hitting
her no no no no no no no she was you
know it's so funny because she said
she's like wouldn't that be crazy she
said something to that effect and then I
said and then she we started joking and
we started like planning a trip that we
were never gonna take yeah but we were
texting each other like fun things hey
do you know they have windsurfing and it
was really fun it was really fun yeah
and then I was like this is almost fun
I'll never go on the trip with her it's
more fun it's more fun yeah yeah and I
was like I want to start planning trips
with people that I'll never do yeah but
just yeah plan them like I have a chat
thread with Joe DeRosa Ari shaffir Shane
Gillis salvocano and the I don't know
what it was but the last thing someone
said was are you guys here and then
randomly jodarosa goes like two weeks
ago just goes is anyone coming or not
and then Ari goes I'm on my way I'm
getting wine and then Sal's like do we
need food
we're talking about a thing that's never
going to happen and it's so [__] fun
you're really tapping into one of my
cornerstone beliefs which is everything
is an excuse to love and that sounds so
basic that's great but this planning a
party isn't the party it's just a way to
say with subtitles on I see you you're
valuable to me I remember you I'm
holding space for you and I love you
that's all of it so Instagram [__]
this podcast stand-up comedy even an
argument like can become an excuse to
love and that sounds so basic all of the
profound truths in my life sound so
trite but when you really like when that
explodes like fireworks I love I love
that more than anything yeah I love the
you know when I I I love loving things
that's number one I love loving things
yeah and I love getting into things and
I love
uh I was talking to someone about uh uh
I love going to live shows as a comedian
who does live shows I love going to live
shows I love going to live shows at
venues I've performed at yeah to see
what that venue's like yeah and I love
my favorite part you know someone said
why do they even do pre-sale when you do
uh tour dates I said previous sales for
the people that love does pre-sale is
when I know that I know I've done a
little bit of work
set it on my calendar I got an alarm
that comes up I know the TR the code and
then I can buy good tickets for this for
a good price and a good section yeah
that's for me it's and by the way I do
it on mine that's for the people that
love and so then yeah and I go my
favorite thing to do is I did it for
Steely Dan I was I went through a huge
like Resurgence of Steely Dan over the
over the pandemic like really listen to
a lot of Steely Dan and then Steely Dan
was coming here and I said I immediately
I got on pre-sale
I bought a box at the Hollywood Bowl I
got the whole box I bought all the
tickets
and then I got to plan I got to I first
wanted something to look forward to but
I got to plan my night I got to fall in
love with the thing like really take my
time and I said to my wife who do we
want to go yeah
and she goes well you know you've been
listening Steely Dan a lot with your
trainer you should invite your trainer
and I was like yeah yeah because we've
been listening to it a lot we're both
into Steely Dan like oh you know what
her roommate is Antonio lofasa one of
the best chefs in La
at at the Hollywood Bowl you cater your
own dinner yeah let's have Antonio
Antonio cater our dinner and then I I
I gotta be honesty Pete I didn't enjoy
the show because I because all the fun
was over for me the fun of planning the
fun of wondering do they sell
sweatshirts the fun of and then I got
there and they didn't sell us my shirts
and I was cold not because I didn't
bring us to my shirt and then he didn't
play all the songs I wanted him to play
everyone had a blast but I was like it's
over it's almost like I was like [__]
it's like like if you plan on having sex
with your wife at night and then you
talk about it all day and you're
flirting on text and then the second you
penetrate you're like well this is gonna
be over in a [__] couple minutes and
then I'm not getting this again was way
ahead of you I was gonna say I dated a
woman long distance and there's no and
Val and I dated long distance that's my
wife and there's nothing better than
those times where we're like vows coming
this weekend you're at work and you
remember and you're absolutely right as
soon as the car is in the garage you're
just like T-minus is 35 seconds what do
you want to get a pizza yeah exactly
like it's it's I the the the
every time we go to Hawaii every we go
to Hawaii not fairly often but we've
gone a bunch with the girls every time
we go to Hawaii
I get so bummed yeah like day two where
I go it's almost over yeah it's almost
it's just it's an I think that's what
I'm going through in my life right now
at 50 I go so [__] I lived I mean first
of all it's a blessing to have lived
this long at all because I know people
that didn't make it here if I go
it's like 20 25 more years 25 the way I
live do you want 20 30. yeah I think
we'll get 30. I don't know maybe about
some some they'll fix something there's
got to be some technology that shows up
and so you're one of those Anchor Tattoo
old [__] yeah it's like I had four
martinis this morning and you're like
90. but like you look 110. yeah yeah
yeah
yeah but like I go but I I wonder if
like I love
the planning the trip I love the the
airport ride yeah I love the [__]
flight I love Landing I love that first
night's dinner and then everything after
that I start going I start going like
[__] it's almost over that's one of the
tricks of life but we don't have to wait
to try and do it we can do it right now
it's dropping anchor into it like I
catch myself what's next Wednesday's
over like I'm having a great time yeah
it's okay it's okay it's running it's
like sand running through our hands and
it's we can either Panic or we can just
go like that's what it is and that's
actually what informs the beauty of it I
really think if you knew because okay
I'll tell you this story we went to Bora
Bora and we were having such a great
time I don't even know anything about it
but I already love this it's the Canary
Islands of of the French Polynesians so
we're in Bora Bora and uh we actually
had our baby with us it was awesome and
you know we were there for six days or
something and around day five we
chrysured it we were like what are we
doing why are we going back and we're
like let's stay for like 12 days yeah
let's stay for two weeks we just
extended it kept the room [__] nuts
we went we machined it yeah on day 10 I
was like what is this hell
is this some sort of Hell Realm
the hardest the hardest I've ever left
not the hardest but one of the most
purest sentences that made me fall out
of my chair laughing
Matt Frost he's an agent over at CAA I
think I do know fresh Frost Frosty is
the best I love Frosty to death he used
to be my agent for a long time
he's the best there's I there's I love
that guy
so me and him were doing a show
like with Jay Moore in Hawaii and the
trip was uh three days
you fly in
day off performing then you fly out the
next day and or maybe even that the
other next day
and frosty goes that seems like a short
time to be in Hawaii yeah why fly all
this again he goes he goes what does she
want to extend our trips I said yeah
let's fix in our trips here's how long
ago what a week he's like yeah [__]
we'll do a stand extra week
we do the show we're having a great time
in Frosty and I everyone's like I gotta
leave my Frosty like not us not us
everyone leaves
we spend a day by the beach we get drunk
the next morning we wake up to go to
breakfast and frosty has this look on
his face and I go what and he goes stop
it yes six more days
and I go yeah and he goes
the exact same thing
I said yeah and he goes should we get
jobs
and I
we get jobs it was just it was the
funniest thing because you're like yeah
what like what are we doing just sitting
here like what are we doing with our
lives like we we're just and then that's
what I mean when you are at a hotel that
only has seven different dinners and
you've had each of them twice yeah
you're asking for a handgun for dessert
that's what I love touring is that never
gets old yeah it never like we leave we
leave on we live on uh we leave Sunday
or Monday to go out to New York to start
this fully loaded tour and the girls are
coming with me both girls they're B
George's bring a friend Leanne's gonna
be on the tour and I go this is what I
can do for the rest of my life if my
girls would just give up on their dreams
and just live with me yeah and live with
me on a tour bus and just everyone works
for dad like do it Ozzy Osbourne style
yeah like the whole [__] family just
[__] focuses around Dad yeah I could
do that for the rest of my goddamn life
oh I would never get off to her I would
never get off tour I'd buy them a tour
bus I'd buy the dogs a tour bus I've
been [__]
love that I would love that there's a
great feeling dude the best tour I've
ever been on was when during the
pandemic we did that I created the
drive-in movie theater tour and the very
first day we got all we all tested we
all got on the bus so everyone tested
negative and we went this is our bubble
we can't leave this bubble no one we've
no one interacts with anyone steal and
we lived in a bubble on a tour bus
for I think like six weeks
and I was like this is everything yeah
this is everything that's what we were
saying about the search it's I didn't I
use the word bubble yeah it's like you
want to shrink we're not supposed to
know as many people as we know we're not
supposed to know as much information as
we know we're not supposed to know as
much and you know people's animals were
not designed to hold off I should not
have a phone no like I actually you also
shouldn't be getting updates on the like
political infrastructure of of Sicily
yeah you know what I mean you hear about
the unrest in Sicily the market can we
not can we not because I'm trying to
deal with the trash in my in my car yeah
I'm not trying to put down a country's
needs I'm just saying it's overwhelming
when you know everything about everybody
and you're not supposed to you're not
and you're not supposed to know what
every like I could name 300 celebrities
you'd know what each one of them looks
like you know a little bit about each
one of them is [__] wrong I shouldn't
know who uh uh Sebastian Stan is yeah
I shouldn't why do you know who um I
know I know a lot about how rich he is I
know a lot about her I know a lot about
her and I probably shouldn't because
based on my interests yeah you know I'll
tell you I'm sure Nick I didn't mean to
put her down I didn't mean to say
Sebastian Santa but he's a sweet guy
yeah he's a great actor I know a lot
about him he's gorgeous I'm just
picturing Sebastian
um the uh I'll tell you when I when
by 2000
2004 2002 2003 right around then
cell phones were really like big it was
like really turn the corner
and I I Leanne got me into therapy and I
said to the therapist
um like I think my phone rang in therapy
and I went oh I'm not answering that she
goes why would you answer that so I
don't know who it is I don't want to
talk to someone this is the beginning of
cell phones right you have a social
anxiety disorder and I was like no I was
like hold on hang on don't don't take
the technology of today and then start
applying [__] I go I don't everyone
answer my phone I won't reply to anyone
I just wish I didn't have one she was
like yeah but you do and I went but
what about 12 years ago when this didn't
exist what was your diagnosis 12 years
ago when someone like I go there's this
this isn't real this is a new thing and
you're now applying my [__] up
behaviors to something that wasn't here
12 years ago right and I remember being
really upset the same therapist told me
by the way I said I'm a fear of flying
she was when was the last time he flew I
said [__] Monday she goes well then
you don't have a fear and I was like
hang on she was people that have a fear
don't fly so we're done with that you're
good what else and I went
the [__] and then I also told this lady
I said a lot of bad things to this lady
oh if I hope she's listening so I'd like
to apologize
I told her uh she was unattractive and
uh she was unattractive and uh I was
shutting down and I said uh
I said
I was like so wait I go do you have a
mortgage she goes I don't know why
that's important I said well as long as
you have a mortgage I'm at problems
because I'm my my problems are paying
for your mortgage so like I'm never
gonna get done with this therapy's not
being done with it and I went no but
like I'm just I get like I want to know
what extra could you have a boat because
if you have a boat then I'm worried that
I'm gonna have more problems because
you're gonna say we need to come twice a
day you want a therapist with a 800 a
month apartment and then I said and then
I said no we can be honest in therapy
right and she said yeah I said well
I'm like I'm attractive to you so like
I'm you're always getting be excited
that for me to come in because I'm more
attractive than you and so yeah I said
this to this therapist she was like I'm
so confused and I went well no I'm just
saying like if I had if I was a
therapist and there was a really hot
chick that I would look forward to her
and I'd be like yo you're probably like
I would always make sure that she's not
going anywhere so I go so I feel like
I'm never gonna be done with therapy
because I'm more attractive than you and
you have a mortgage and she was like
uh she goes I think quite honestly you
need to find a new therapist and I was
like I agree I agree and I was like I
need one that doesn't have a mortgage
and it's [__] hot as [__] she was
like wow this is you know
that's a very funny story obviously and
there's there's some there's something
going on there oh buddy my therapist who
just did the podcast would admit that
our sessions were like funny and
interesting so that he he had to be
alert as to not withhold healing yeah or
or some piece of advice that he's like
you know I'll tell you next week you
know like because maybe he wanted to
it's interesting it also but it does
presuppose that the therapist is sitting
on some sort of golden ticket really
they're just there to create a space
where you do the work on yourself yeah
well you gotta you gotta well first of
all you gotta trust in therapy I didn't
trust in therapy at the time yeah I did
not I was put into therapy I was putting
therapy by everyone around me going like
you should go do therapy yeah that's
tricky that's like when other people get
you sober like it's it's a little bit
more helpful when you go like I need
therapy this latest run of therapy was
like me saying well because I stopped
doing therapy because I was talking too
much
and I could not get my voice to rebound
so to talk for an extra hour yeah it was
really [__] me up I was just looking
at that you have one of those see up
there on the top show oh I can't I can't
have humidity anywhere in my lungs why
uh it clogs them up like I can't go into
steam rooms really
yeah my lungs will be like as even just
talking about a psychosomatic my lungs
ever since I was a kid if I slept near a
humidifier I'd wake up with a chest
infection really yeah I don't know what
it is I can't do uh Mucinex
um I think I have allergy induced I
don't know what the [__] wrong with me
anyway you ever see a ghost ghost yeah
yeah
[Music]
what do you think that has to do with my
lungs
I'm bringing this in for a landing [__]
yes
[__] yes I have [__] yes dude I hardcore
believe in ghosts
tell me your ghost we went to uh it was
a Monday
Yelp review we went to Alcatraz I I know
you can Google this and you can find the
exact stats of the things I'm talking
about
so we went to Alcatraz I called Zach
Baggins and I said hey we're going to
Alcatraz I want to have an interaction
with the with the ghost he said okay
Zach's like ghost adventurers oh okay on
Travel Channel he is obviously the
foremost expert in in paranormal
activity in the world right now right uh
he said here's what you do
get lost get lost find a place hunker
down
and and welcome them in have a
conversation with them like literally
like scare yourself get yourself scared
and then that that's when and so I said
okay so he's like they like the fear I
don't I don't know but like you said
like put yourself out there like go down
and say like hey I'm here
I'm ready to I'm I want I want to meet
you or whatever like welcome them right
and so
because no unfriendly Spirits ever
passed through yeah Alcatraz I I have so
many jokes about this I have so many
jokes about this I have so many jokes
about this like it's because you know
because I was like how come all these
jokes are these these ghosts are
progressive where are the racist ghosts
why is there a black guy holding a
camera
who's letting the woman talk someone
smack her please in my day no woman
would tell you you're a man what to do
why isn't she listened so
um
like so it's always just Boo and then
they're done yeah just you came back
from the other side to say boo yeah like
there should be one ghost that's like
like in in anyway anyway so we go to
Alcatraz
and the and I and I start kind of
Disappearing getting lost and then and
then I I'd catch up with a private tour
private peel off private tour we're
taking we're taking there at uh midnight
uh on a boat over to Alcatraz we're the
only ones on the entire Island other
than the one guy taking us around and
showing us the entire facility Well it's
what I worked for Travel Channel
so we have a film crew with us so I kind
of get lost but I catch up with the
thing and then at one point I'm talking
to ghosts and I'm like you know like
trying to to open up and they put me in
a cell and the cell gets locked and they
can't unlock it and I'm like and
everyone's like this is like not planned
not planned and they can't unlock it and
they're like hold on give a second
this has never happened and I start
really getting scared like actually
really getting scared in a weird way
like I have a panic attack going like
what if they can't what if what if it's
gonna takes like a
a minute to get to like a couple weeks
or like a week or a day to get this what
if they have to bring in the chainsaw
and [__] yeah yeah and then I'm like
and then it unlocks and I'm like okay
but I got really scared I got genuinely
scared
so then
everyone goes up uh to the to like the
infirmary I think and I
tell the guy I'm gonna go wander I'm
gonna wander and I know there's cameras
kind of watching me wander it's we're
filming everything
I'm gonna wander I said where's like the
[__] scariest place he goes uh
downstairs uh in um
isolation like where they isolation is
pretty [__] sketchy I said really and
he goes you gotta go down go down the
doors do not lock it so don't worry but
go down close the door you can [__]
find one it'll [__] freak you out so
I go down I go down to uh where the
isolation where they put the guy really
if by the solo by himself yeah I go down
and I start looking and I find one
and I go in and I shut the door
and I'm like
all right
my name is Bert I'm here and I'm for
real I want to see you I want to I want
to talk to you I want to know that
you're real I want to feel your presence
and I see a red light in the corner I go
God damn it they put a [__] GoPro in
here right they put a [__] GoPro in
here
they're F and so in a weird way I get
very comfortable because I know there's
a camera filming yeah so I play up a
little bit and I go I'm not scared of
you I don't know what you did but I know
you're a coward for doing it and because
it's a criminal it's a criminal right I
don't know who you hurt
but you're not going to hurt me today
and all of a sudden it gets ice cold in
there and I'm like and I get chill bumps
top to bottom all over my body and I'm
like and I feel a presence on me and I'm
like and I see the red light and I'm
like okay
I'm not I'm getting chill bumps right
now I go I'm not scared I'm not scared
and I hear a [__] like a slam and I'm
like [__] I'm scared and I get
out Noah in my head I go they got the
shot and I get out and I [__] pop out
and no one's around and I go over and I
find my cameraman and like where'd you
go and I said I went down to solitary uh
whatever confinement and then like
really I said yeah and I I'm like have
you guys been down there and they're
like no where is it and so I take them
down and I go it's down here and then I
was like hold on uh I go listen to the
producer I go do you want to jump in and
grab the GoPro she was my GoPro I said
you guys put a GoPro there's a red light
in the corner I know there's a GoPro and
I just you know it's good footage I did
get scared and I did run out in a
[__] thing but there's a GoPro she
goes there's no GoPro in there and then
the guy says this is solitary
confinement and if you really want to
get spooked go in there and if you talk
if you see a ghost you'll see a little
red light people say they've seen a red
light and I went hold on so I go in
there with a flashlight and the same one
and there's no [__] I'm looking
everywhere for a red light I shut the
door no [__] red light and I'm like
oh my God the red light was the ghost I
Google it I swear to God Google it and I
Google it you'll find it I I haven't
found it but that guy said it on the
tour and I was like I was in there with
the real [__] ghost but we'll find
time and then I was terrified I was
terrified I wouldn't leave my camera
crew side I was like there's [__]
ghosts in here and we [__] left we
got off the thing I started drinking
whiskey right away and then I was like
let's get the [__] out of here his
spirits lead to Spirits often yeah I
can't believe I can yeah and I'm
terrified oh I uh I have I've been
molested by a ghost I think I was raped
by a ghost one time tell me uh my body
people have talked about this before do
we just talk about this
Kesha was talking about it you all
sudden you almost get sleep paralysis
where your body you're kind of awake but
you're dreaming but you're kind of awake
and you're present and your body is held
down it was when it was the first time
it ever happened I was probably 12 years
old 14 years old maybe 12 or 13. and I
was held down in my bed and my body
couldn't move and I felt a woman a
female on top of me take control of my
body and have sex with me I'd never had
sex before but and then I had a
nocturnal Mission I had a wet dream and
I went and then all of a sudden I could
get up and as I got up I checked and I
was like oh my God I just had a wet
dream like what the [__] what the [__]
was that but I got completely I had a I
had complete and total lucid dreaming
where I had sex with someone lucid and
I've had and I had a nocturnal emission
and I was like and it happened to me a
couple times in college and it happened
to me it happened to me as an adult it's
happened to me before but never not not
consistently like wet dreams but that
first time when I was like 13 [__]
full-blown wet dream like sometimes you
can't finish yeah a lot of times a lot
of times
to a lot of guys I don't want to get
pregnant
by the way so one of my first jobs was
being a reenactor in Salem Massachusetts
and we did the The Witch Trials right oh
my God for real yeah and and one of the
testimonies was I was laying in my bed
and her name was a good wife Bishop
appeared straddling me they're all like
kind of like your story like she was
sending her spirit to kind of like jump
my bones or or [__] with me or scare me
or whatever it might be so your story is
like at the very least
written on our DNA as something that
like happens to human beings and also
quite possibly
like a real paranormal phenomenon dude I
would
I've had I've had a few things that are
crazy crazy paranormal stuff but like
those are the ones like I woke up I
heard a slam one time in my old old
house and I woke up and every door I
always sleep with all doors shut I
always sleep with all my doors shut and
every door was exactly half open even
the closets like and we lived in Cecil B
to millswold house
it's so funny last night last night
my cousin comes over and my wife's
giving a tour of our of our the house we
currently live in to her she's walking
through all the rooms and I and we go to
the front room and I go the man that
lives here before this is the room he
died and she goes no he died in the in
our room and I went what excuse me died
in our room and I go he did she was like
you didn't know that and I was like no I
thought he died in the front room she
was why would he die in the front room
he died in his bedroom like oh he died
in our room she's like yeah why does
that scare you I go yeah I was like you
could have never told me that he died in
the corner with a GoPro she's like
there's no GoPro there was a house we
looked at one time and there was a body
Mark in between two of the rooms because
the guy had died and he had been there
for a while and it burned into the wood
and you could see on the ground on the
wood you can see his body mark on the
wood
wow and I was like you're reminding me
that when uh I was in Amsterdam there's
a there's something called The Museum of
death and we've never been there yeah oh
really oh I've been to answer my damn a
lot and I did a TV show in Amsterdam so
yeah so you've been there when we went
there we were very stoned uh terrible
idea and you know it so they rent plots
in Amsterdam in in the Netherlands so
you get a plot for a certain amount of
time but then they dig you up they
exhume you and then this Museum terrible
idea is just people's belongings that
they found in their coffins so it's
literally just old glasses and a pocket
watch and a handkerchief and it's you're
walking around and you're just like
first of all it's like quite a ways
outside of the city it's not really a
museum it's just kind of like a building
and three the people giving the tour
looked like they were at gunpoint they
were so scared the tour people were
terrified they were it wasn't an act
this was like the most boring Museum and
they were like and um in this room we
have some of the baby coffins you know
and and then a door slammed and the
woman jumped and screamed and it was not
part of the fun oh she was just like I
picked the wrong choice Zach and Zach
and uh Aaron Goodwin or the Run Ghost
Adventures who goes what I think I'm
saying it right and they have I was
friends with them and they would we'd
and they would say they would go to
these houses and they'd bring Spirits
home with them and they and that their
houses were then [__] because they'd
have spirits in their houses that they
that and Zach has bought I mean you do
have to Google and I don't want to say
because I don't want to misrepresent it
but Zach has bought like
beds Mass murderers killed their victims
on and he bought the house Linda Bianca
lived in right around here yeah the
where where the chart where the Met he
bought that house or maybe not Linda no
Linda Bianca Linda Bianca was one of the
one before Sharon Tate right I don't
know she was her husband was a was a uh
a supermarket Mogul okay and they killed
her I think the Bianca's and he bought
the bed and he bought the house the
house the house that they wanted the
house because he's into that for
whatever his his love is yeah his
paranormal resale yeah his yeah his
pre-sale code is death okay let's we're
gonna lighten the mood good call bring
it in for Atlantic I I I love this mood
I just yeah yeah two one note because
this is Freaky Deaky and you already
kind of did it since you did the show
like over I feel like eight years ago
was that the last time I did your show
was it the it was a meltdown
it was about eight years oh my God yeah
it was crazy I you know what I remember
from it we were riffing so much at one
point you went we're dancing like we
were laughing and we didn't really know
each other no yeah
um
anyway I had another memory I remember
when sigura did it he was on the phone
and he was whispering what Dave
Chappelle said like Chappelle had all
those jokes about Louie and you remember
there's a climate that you couldn't even
like say the jokes that Chappelle said
about it because we were still kind of
it was baby steps of a new time and I
remember cigarette before he went in as
if he was you know saying the nuclear
nuclear launch codes he was like yeah
and he said [__] you can't hang up the
phone it was like that and I was like
wow that was that was a very interesting
time
um okay what was I saying oh you already
said it that one of the times you
laughed the hardest in your life you
already said one
this is the new question we ask at the
end can you think of the time you
laughed the hardest the most in your
life but
you don't have to burden yourself with
finding the time
is there a time where you're laughing to
the point of Tears maybe you're a kid
maybe someone fell maybe someone farted
speaking of which I thought of a roast
joke for you I was like you can't stop
working you're like the frumpy Kevin
Hart you're like Kevin fart it's not
quite right Kevin Sharp you're Kevin
shot yeah thank you you just improved it
Bert's like Kevin Short
um I can quantify down I can only
because only because I love laughter I'm
gonna give you I'm gonna give you just a
couple of my favorite laughs I've ever
had in my life number one you can find
online and this is one of the hardest
I've ever laughed in my life Tom and I
we just started really hanging out being
friends and we went to Hawaii together
and with with our wives and I was
drinking and he we went upstairs and he
asked me if I would shave his back and
in shaving his back I realized that his
armpit hair was connected to his tit
hair and I said hey man can I just
Hollow that out for you and we're happy
to be recording this what's the matter
yeah and I said what I do is I'll Caesar
my tits I'll Caesar them I'll cut the
hair like this so they look more defined
I'll do it for you you're gonna look so
much better I'm being very earnest stop
it
what this is too much you're saying it
like it's normal but it's not it's so
funny it's not like the weirdest thing
I've ever heard but it's very funny to
have you be like so naturally I said I
can Caesar your tits Caesar amount yeah
I'm dying your armpits I'm getting a
little Diamond under there you look you
look good so I take the Clippers and I
do the first tip and as I bring it
around the corner I'm too close to the
forest to see the trees as I pull back I
realize it looks like his tits are
wearing sunglasses like and and it looks
ridiculous and it looks really bad and I
also in my head I know this is our first
of six days in Hawaii where he's gonna
have to work just double down you should
have done horizontal lines like those
80s sunglasses you should I just made it
look like it and I'm laughing so hard
that I can't apologize and he's like and
all he's saying with very vulnerable
eyes is does it look good and I'm going
oh no it's not it's not great and then
he goes into the bathroom and you can
see the video of me of me lot sitting on
the toilet sweating and I can't stop
laughing because he is not happy and
he's like looks horrible
okay that's one what did he do did you
just shave it all off no no he left it
like that more shirt at the beach the
whole weekend oh my God by the way that
reminds me of one of my other favorite
moments in the machine what is when the
guy has his throat cut and you go don't
touch it it's bad it's been bad dad
don't touch it it's bad
um uh the another another time I was we
were smoking weed I was smoking weed
with my sister
and both my sisters and we were on
Catalina Island and we were the big
group we were camping and someone said
you know there's Buffalo here and my
sister said really and they said yeah
the owner for the the Cubs they used to
do spring training out here and so the
owner for the Cubs brought out like he
owned it they did their spring training
and he brought the Buffalo out
for for for that for he brought the
Buffalo out and my sister goes for a
scrimmage
and I went huh she and then I had a
visual of the Cubs warming up on the
home field side throwing thing the owner
coming out in a seersucker suit with a
big cigar and a [__] Straw Hat seeing
the Cubs warming out and then looking
over and seeing Buffalo grazing on the
other side for the visitor team and goes
I meant the [__] team not the gut and
so and I couldn't stop laughing I could
not stop [__] laughing I could not
stop laughing
I could I was just all I could hear was
in my head that okay another one to
scrimmage
sagura tells me that he has met Jennifer
Aniston this you can find this one
online he tells me that he's met
Jennifer Aniston and I go bro I thought
we were a [__] team like if you're
gonna meet Jennifer Aniston you got to
bring me with you and he tells him it
says long story at the end he tells me
it's a lie and I go why the [__] would
you do that send that to me yeah that's
big lies that's why I go I go hold on
you've established one fact and that is
if we meet Jennifer Aniston We're doing
it together and he goes okay that's a
deal and I go he goes where should we do
it and I said well we mean where should
we do it okay we're not doing it at your
house because and I go and we can't do
it in my house it's too small we'll do
it at her house
and he goes do we bring our wives and I
go no we're not bringing our [__]
wives and he goes can I go can she bring
someone and he says yeah she can bring
someone for safety and then I go and
then he goes maybe that's not the
message we want to put out and I start
laughing so hard because I can all I can
see is his eyes saying
for safety and then he goes maybe that's
not the message and I could not stop
laughing it's the heart it's one of the
hardest I've ever laughed in my life
because I need security for both of us
and he's like maybe that's not the
message you want to put up I laughed so
hard I laughed so hard
and then but only followed by the
hardest I've ever laughed and I'm and I
and please caveat I may find harder
times I've left yeah the hardest times
I've ever left is when I told him I
drank a gallon of Kool-Aid and I didn't
understand why he was laughing at first
is this the most recent clip that's the
most recent clip is we were sitting
there and he said
um
he said what do you got in there I said
Kool-Aid and I'm being so honest and
that's I know that's I'm so Earnest I'm
at the funniest when I'm not trying to
be funny you're not trying I watched
this club I loved it and he goes what
flavor I go red red and he's like red
Kool-Aid I said it's the best try it I
said get yourself some and so he pours a
cup he goes this really is Kool-Aid I go
yeah what did you think it was I'm at
the time I don't think there's anything
to mock about what I'm doing he sips it
he goes this is you're drinking a gallon
Kool-Aid I said yeah and he goes
he starts laughing and he goes people
look at you and they go look at that guy
he's so healthy he's drinking water
you're drinking Kool-Aid and as soon as
he said that I went oh yeah maybe that's
not so healthy and then he goes you're
drinking Kool-Aid you're drinking a
gallon of Kool-Aid and as he's laughing
I'm realizing oh this is not healthy but
I thought it was healthy and I'm like
because it's so watery because it's so
watery and I'm going oh yeah and then as
he's laughing I'm realizing how
ridiculous I am and at one point I go
doesn't you ever not realize how
different you are until someone points
it out and you're like I'm really
different and I and that when we laughed
at Kool-Aid and I'd never watched it I'd
never watched it we just had a good
laugh and then I sent it I sent it to my
dad and my my dad my dad was for
Thanksgiving my dad says uh buddy two
bears thing is that like a it's like a
big deal I said no it's just our podcast
and he was like yeah but my friends have
said the there's a Kool-Aid clip and I
went oh yeah like I drink I drink
Kool-Aid and he goes huh I said well I
don't know and we're at my sister's
house I could just play the club I'd
never seen it and my dad was crying
laughing and he and he goes you drink a
gallon of Kool-Aid you drink a get a
Kool-Aid and I was like I was like and
again I'm going I didn't realize how
[__] up and I watched it the first
time yeah and I was crying I was like
seeing someone else's life it really was
a weird guy drinking a gallon of
Kool-Aid yeah a grown man a grown man
but bird
here you are today yeah drinking a
gallon of Kool-Aid I I it's I can't stop
[Laughter]
it's red
little kid is it red it's so good oh
well we're not going to be able to top
what a great edit you are a dream yes
buddy I love you I love you I love
having talks with you you're so [__]
great thanks man you're so [__] great
let's get together this next let's see
the end of the summer let's do some
shows together do some dinner I mean
Oxnard shows don't call them Oxford well
we call it oxy's and Oxnard
it's probably been taken
um I would love any excuse to do
something together and laugh again what
a delight you are would you everybody go
see the machine I clearly please check
it out it should be on should be coming
out on VOD I think it's got one more
week in theaters VOD it'll be in
theaters for a while but VOD is coming
out and then it's worth seeing in the
theater and then and then we'll be out
I'm sure we'll be on a streamer soon the
other the other joke I love with Mark
Hamill getting out of the car playing
your dad and he goes now this is the
kind of Russian architecture I was
hoping to see see I was like that joke
there was so much of that that we had to
cut out just for time just him being
just him being hit or he was really
there was so many [__] funny one we
have a great moment that we had to cut
for time of me and him inside the
[__] train station yeah oh it was
great sets by the way too that train
looked dope oh yeah and also here's a
great I think he's so Mark Hamill is so
funny in it and I don't know if he gives
a [__] but I'm like it was zero percent
Skywalker he completely vanished he just
was that guy but I'm saying those best
movies ever been in
that is
overly a new hopeful yeah
I said Mark
let's set up for a seat yeah
yeah it is the Mexican Mafia I mean
we'll see I'll be there
um would you say keep we wrote it out
for you keep it crispy it's just how we
end thanks of course just say it to me
you can just say it to me hey Pete
keep it crispy
we did we did today
[Music]